Shure: 嘎嘎香
Katrina: 然后还要干什么
Katrina: So, what else do we need to do?
Shure: 然后烧炭就可以起锅
Shure: Then we just need to light the charcoal and start cooking.
Katrina: 烧炭
Katrina: Light the charcoal.
Shure: 开始一会我不知道
Shure: Let's start, although I'm not sure yet.
Shure: 这个咸蛋我有点掌握不好
Shure: I'm not very confident with these salted eggs.
Shure: 然后一会如果淡了
Shure: If they end up being bland...
Shure: 就直接就是巨大的面团啊
Shure: We'll just have a huge dough ball.
Jake:这是什么肉啊
Jake: What kind of meat is this?
Jake:这都牛肉和鸡肉
Jake: This is all beef and chicken.
Shure: 这全是牛肉
Shure: It's all beef.
Shure: 然后这是鸡肉和排骨
Shure: And this is chicken and ribs.
Jake:哟看起来很厉害
Jake: Wow, looks impressive.
Shure: 绝绝对香
Shure: It smells absolutely amazing.
Shure: 跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 一般不来长春都尝不到这手艺的
Shure: You usually can't taste this kind of skill unless you come to Changchun.
Alice:酸啊
Alice: It's sour.
Shure: 今儿是偷偷漏抖都给你们了
Shure: Today, I'm secretly giving you all my best.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 是烤的话是要在外面烤吗
Lucia: If it's grilled, do we need to grill it outside?
Shure: 这比我女朋友都早
Shure: This is even earlier than my girlfriend.
Jake:对那边有个好家
Jake: Yes, there's a good spot over there.
Shure: 迟了两周
Shure: Two weeks late.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Jake:啊早谁谁早吃那两周啊
Jake: Ah, who ate those two weeks earlier?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 比我女朋友
Shure: Earlier than my girlfriend.
Jake:他还没吃
Jake: He hasn't eaten yet.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 那我们周日是还要弄这些是吗
Shure: So, we're doing this again on Sunday, right?
Jake:对周日还要弄
Jake: Yes, we're doing it again on Sunday.
Shure: 啊那应该也能吃
Shure: Ah, then we should be able to eat it too.
Alice:周日不是不吃饭吗
Alice: Aren't we not eating on Sunday?
Alice:就是加冰
Alice: Just add ice.
Jake:这烤烤一点
Jake: Grill a bit more.
Katrina: 好一点
Katrina: It'll be better.
Alice:哦提前搞一点
Alice: Oh, prepare a bit in advance.
Katrina: 好一
Katrina: Okay, one moment.
Shure: 意思一下懂了吧
Shure: You get the idea, right?
Jake:你的意思一下
Jake: Just a bit of your idea.
Jake:或者剩一点给他哈哈哈
Jake: Or maybe leave a little for him, haha.
Lucia: 这外头除了那圈墙
Lucia: Outside there's only that wall.
Alice:啊剩一点
Alice: Ah, leave a bit.
Alice:哈哈哈真嘟假嘟
Alice: Hahaha, really?
Lucia: 外头是不除了那圈墙灯没有别的灯了
Lucia: Outside, apart from that wall light, there's no other light.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:就是这5个灯
Jake: It's just these five lights.
Jake:我我可以去打光
Jake: I can set up the lighting.
Jake:就是你要什么灯吗
Jake: Do you need any specific lights?
Lucia: 哦没有没有
Lucia: Oh no, no.
Lucia: 不是我是说如果要在外面烤的话
Lucia: I mean, if we're grilling outside...
Lucia: 外面其实还有点黑
Lucia: It's still a bit dark outside.
Jake:啊对没关系
Jake: Ah, it's fine.
Alice:火一点起来应该好一点吧
Alice: It should be better once the fire is going.
Jake:这氛围到位了
Jake: The atmosphere is perfect.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 但是只有那个就是炉子那里会亮一点
Lucia: But only the stove area will be a bit bright.
Lucia: 咱们吃饭的桌子还挺黑的啊
Lucia: Our dining table is quite dark.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不过有那个那个影棚灯
Lucia: But we have those studio lights.
Alice:先找点纸盒点火吧
Alice: Let's find some cardboard to start the fire.
Alice:还是有火枪啥的
Alice: Or do we have a blowtorch or something?
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Shure: 呃我想想我下一步要
Shure: Uh, let me think about my next step.
Shure: 做什么呃
Shure: What should I do next? Uh...
Shure: 这些也可以拿出来
Shure: We can take these out too.
Shure: 羊排
Shure: Lamb chops.
Shure: 大蒜都拿着吃
Shure: Eat with garlic.
Shure: 肉不吃蒜香味少一半呢
Shure: Meat without garlic loses half its flavor.
Alice:你今天晚上想吃这个吗
Alice: Do you want to eat this tonight?
Alice:那我们打开吧
Alice: Then let's open it.
Lucia: 可以吃好的
Lucia: Sure, we can eat it.
Alice:这个蜂蜜给你
Alice: Here's the honey for you.
Lucia: 哦你不你不用这个行
Lucia: Oh, you don't need this, right?
Jake:大师我们做什么呀
Jake: Master, what are we making?
Alice:我不吃蜂蜜的
Alice: I don't eat honey.
Shure: 大师
Shure: Master
Alice:大师你要蒜吗
Alice: Master, do you want garlic?
Shure: 不是别别
Shure: No, no
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 大师蒜拿生吃的
Shure: Master eats raw garlic
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Shure: 对然后把把生菜洗了吧
Shure: Yeah, and wash the lettuce
Shure: 来个人把生菜洗了
Shure: Someone wash the lettuce
Lucia: 生吃大蒜
Lucia: Eating raw garlic
Jake:生菜
Jake: Lettuce
Shure: 没吃过吧
Shure: Haven't tried it before, right?
Shure: 尝尝就知道了
Shure: Try it and you'll know
Lucia: 可以生吃而且就是跟肉在一起
Lucia: You can eat it raw, and with meat too
Tasha: 我知道了但
Tasha: I know, but...
Jake:怎么洗
Jake: How to wash it?
Shure: 生生菜就是洗洗菜
Shure: Just wash the lettuce, like washing veggies
Lucia: 挺好吃的
Lucia: It's pretty tasty
Lucia: 只不过就是吃完之后会有蒜味
Lucia: But it leaves a garlic smell after
Shure: 咋洗他咋洗知道不
Shure: How to wash it, do you know?
Shure: 拿个盆装里面
Shure: Put it in a bowl
Shure: 然后把生菜洗了
Shure: And then wash the lettuce
Lucia: 所以一般很少这样
Lucia: So it's not done often
Jake:干哈干哈干哈
Jake: What are you doing, what are you doing?
Jake:咱要干嘛
Jake: What are we doing?
Shure: 就是把生菜洗
Shure: Just washing the lettuce
Jake:洗洗生菜
Jake: Wash the lettuce
Shure: 就剩生菜没洗了啊
Shure: The lettuce is the only thing left unwashed
Shure: 那个土豆
Shure: And the potatoes
Alice:生菜没洗
Alice: The lettuce isn't washed
Shure: 土豆想吃的话就削了
Shure: If you want to eat the potatoes, peel them
Shure: 然后切成片
Shure: Then slice them
Alice:开开瓶
Alice: Open the bottle
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure
Katrina: 好了麻烦你们起一下这个
Katrina: Okay, can you guys get up for a moment?
Alice:我没有盆吗
Alice: Do we not have a bowl?
Jake:没有吧
Jake: I don't think so
Jake:这锅怎么长这样这锅怎么长这样
Jake: Why does this pot look like this? Why does this pot look like this?
Alice:有人要纯酸奶吗
Alice: Anyone want plain yogurt?
Alice:比较酸的
Alice: It's quite sour
Jake:这锅为什么长成这个样子
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Jake:可以吃可以吃
Jake: It's edible, it's edible.
Lucia: 嗯那就3个
Lucia: Hmm, then three of them.
Alice:纯酸奶无糖的好
Alice: Plain yogurt, unsweetened is good.
Jake:嗯可以吃
Jake: Hmm, it's edible.
Tasha: 好没事
Tasha: Okay, no problem.
Lucia: 没事我可以把这个蜂蜜分享给你
Lucia: No problem, I can share this honey with you.
Alice:还有人吗还有人吗
Alice: Is there anyone else? Is there anyone else?
Lucia: 白砂糖也可以加
Lucia: You can also add white sugar.
Tasha: 其实还有人吗
Tasha: Actually, is there anyone else?
Alice:还有人吗
Alice: Is there anyone else?
Jake:好
Alice:微微你是纯酸奶吗
Alice: Tasha, do you have plain yogurt?
Jake:我给你清掉这个东西
Jake: I'll clean this up for you.
Alice:那我们3个
Alice: Then the three of us.
Lucia: 行那我拿两个碗
Lucia: Okay, then I'll get two bowls.
Lucia: 正好我刚洗完眉那个玩意
Lucia: Just finished washing my eyebrows.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 这也没放油
Shure: There's no oil here either.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: Just remembered.
Jake:发生什么事
Jake: What happened?
Shure: 是吧是没放油吧再倒点
Shure: Right? There's no oil, add some more.
Shure: 你看看不行了吧
Shure: Look, it won't work, right?
Lucia: 我把我把手再冲一下去
Lucia: I'll go wash my hands again.
Alice:不放油也行吧
Alice: It's okay not to add oil, right?
Lucia: 我刚抓了那个生蚝袋子
Lucia: I just grabbed that oyster bag.
Shure: 不不行不行
Shure: No, it won't work.
Shure: 得放下去
Shure: You need to add it.
Alice:你考的时候不是也要刷他吗
Alice: Don't you brush it when you grill it?
Shure: 不刷不刷
Shure: No, no brushing.
Shure: 直接烤
Shure: Just grill directly.
Alice:不刷呦
Alice: No brushing?
Jake:丢我嫌丢
Jake: I'm annoyed, just throw it away.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 拿筷子别上手了
Shure: Use chopsticks, don't use your hands.
Shure: 让你偷学
Shure: Trying to steal the technique.
Shure: 你都不学全了
Shure: But you didn't learn it completely.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后到时候出去骂教的不对退钱
Shure: Then you'll go out and blame the teaching, asking for a refund.
Katrina: 哈到时候出去别说我是修硕学生
Katrina: Haha, when you go out, don't say you're Shure's student.
Katrina: 我要放歌
Katrina: I want to play some music.
Shure: 放吧把我电脑拿来吧
Shure: Go ahead, bring me my computer.
Shure: 进去拿就行
Shure: Just go in and get it.
Shure: 应该没有你什么不能看的吧
Shure: There shouldn't be anything you can't see, right?
Shure: 闭着眼睛进去吧
Shure: Just go in with your eyes closed.
Shure: 哈哈哈有
Shure: Hahaha, there is.
Shure: 密码吗有
Shure: Password? Yeah, it has one.
Jake:黄丝球是我瞎还是不在这
Jake: Is the yellow ball gone, or am I just blind?
Lucia: 是好像是不在这
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like it's not here.
Jake:是我是是不在这OK
Jake: Yeah, it's not here, OK.
Jake:总觉得我看到了又没看到
Jake: I keep thinking I saw it but didn't.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 你可能是看到了那个就是下水的那个
Lucia: You might have seen that thing that goes into the drain.
Katrina: 就怎么用
Katrina: How do I use this?
Katrina: 打开就行是吗
Katrina: Just open it, right?
Shure: 对这个就拧拧它的大小就好
Shure: Yeah, just twist it to adjust the size.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Shure: 随便放吧
Shure: Just play whatever.
Katrina: 哦已经连上了哦
Katrina: Oh, it's already connected.
Shure: 对已经连上
Shure: Yeah, it's connected.
Katrina: 只要直接插就行
Katrina: Just plug it in, right?
Shure: 插上就行
Shure: Yeah, just plug it in.
Tasha: 没有一个地方可以
Tasha: There's no place for it.
Shure: 往里一点别掉
Shure: Push it in a bit more so it doesn't fall.
Alice:嗯我给你
Alice: Hmm, let me help you.
Alice:这个芒果今天晚上要吃的
Alice: This mango is for tonight.
Alice:这好像没有勺吧
Alice: It seems like there are no spoons.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Alice:抱歉了
Alice: Sorry about that.
Alice:用这个
Alice: Use this.
Jake:我操哎呀
Jake: Damn, geez.
Jake:这东西怎么这
Jake: How do you do this?
Jake:能擦干净吗这
Jake: Can this be cleaned up?
Tasha: 不能就算了
Tasha: If not, just forget it.
Alice:是不是有点抽象哈哈哈
Alice: Isn't it a bit abstract? Hahaha.
Tasha: 火吧
Tasha: Fire it up.
Alice:确实有点抽象
Alice: It is a bit abstract.
Lucia: 这个不太好弄还是拿个那个
Lucia: This is hard to deal with, better get another one.
Lucia: 中午啊今天中午外卖没给勺
Lucia: At noon, the delivery didn't come with a spoon.
Lucia: 其他的勺还有用吗
Lucia: Are there any other spoons we can use?
Lucia: 咱一会吃的时候得用勺
Lucia: When we eat later, we need to use a spoon.
Lucia: 啊let me think
Lucia: Ah, let me think.
Lucia: 一次性餐具还有吗
Lucia: Do we still have any disposable utensils?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What stuff?
Lucia: 一次那个一次性餐具
Lucia: The disposable utensils.
Lucia: 因为我们好像没什么勺
Lucia: Because we don't seem to have many spoons.
Lucia: 然后现在要舀这个
Lucia: And now we need to scoop this.
Alice:我用筷子弄的给你选一个吧
Alice: I used chopsticks, let me choose one for you.
Jake:哦一次性勺啊
Jake: Oh, disposable spoons?
Lucia: 随便都行
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 关键在于
Lucia: The key is...
Lucia: 咱们吃的时候要用勺吃
Lucia: We need to use spoons when we eat.
Alice:我用筷子吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks.
Jake:咱要不买一点吧
Jake: How about we buy some?
Jake:买个外卖买
Jake: Order some takeout.
Shure: 我靠下周如果他们不回去的话
Shure: Damn, if they don't go back next week...
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahaha.
Jake:不是不是哈哈哈
Jake: No, no, hahaha.
Jake:就是外卖里面有配送这些商品的
Jake: I mean, takeout usually comes with these items.
Shure: 是不是还能碰上啊
Shure: Might we run into them again?
Alice:给你选一个这
Alice: Let me choose one for you, here.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Jake:这这这有的选吗
Jake: Are there any choices?
Jake:这个左边
Jake: This, this, this one on the left.
Shure: 这怎么主客又颠倒又换
Shure: How come the host and guest roles are reversed again?
Alice:不一样吗
Alice: Aren't they the same?
Tasha: 对啊他写上
Tasha: Yeah, he wrote it down.
Jake:对啊那选啥
Jake: Yeah, so what to choose?
Alice:差不多你随便选
Alice: They’re almost the same, you pick one.
Shure: 我先紧张一会是吧
Shure: Let me get nervous for a bit first.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:这个给你放哪
Alice: Where should I put this for you?
Jake:给我放
Jake: Put it here for me.
Tasha: 好了不用擦了洗不掉了
Tasha: Alright, no need to wipe it, it won't come off.
Tasha: 要把水沾到这个
Tasha: You need to get some water on it.
Tasha: 沾到
Tasha: Get it on.
Lucia: 这个蜂蜜是一个勺型的
Lucia: This honey is shaped like a spoon.
Lucia: 所以我我可以用这个蜂蜜勺吃它
Lucia: So I can use this honey spoon to eat it.
Jake:我算洗完了吗
Jake: Am I done washing?
Tasha: 算现在要把它擦干
Tasha: So now we need to wipe it dry.
Tasha: 就是就是
Tasha: Exactly, exactly.
Tasha: 擦到看
Tasha: Wipe until you see it.
Alice:无油无水状态
Alice: It should be oil-free and water-free.
Tasha: 啊这个明显还有水
Tasha: Ah, there's still water here.
Tasha: 你要拿新的纸再擦一下
Tasha: You need to use a new paper to wipe it again.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你尝一口吗
Jake: Do you want to taste it?
Tasha: 嗯不尝
Tasha: Hmm, no thanks.
Shure: 来借个剪刀把碳打开
Shure: Can someone lend me scissors to open the charcoal?
Tasha: OK啦
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 这包纸封在这就是专门擦他的
Tasha: This pack of paper here is specifically for wiping it.
Jake:哦没看见多少
Jake: Oh, I didn't see much.
Jake:还是瞎了点
Jake: Still a bit blind.
Tasha: 底部就不用擦了里面
Tasha: No need to wipe the inside bottom.
Jake:好
Jake: Got it.
Jake:爱擦就是要擦
Jake: If you love wiping, just wipe it.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Shure: 来个帮我一起引碳的
Shure: Someone help me light the charcoal.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Lucia: 我马上我把这个搅好
Lucia: I'll do it soon, let me finish mixing this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不行
Jake: No way.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿对不起
Jake: Hehehe, sorry.
Jake:7秒的记忆
Jake: 7-second memory.
Tasha: 人不如鱼系列
Tasha: People are worse than fish series.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:锃光瓦亮是不
Jake: Shiny and bright, right?
Alice:是不是得给它弄开啊
Alice: Shouldn't we open it?
Alice:这么大块不好点吧
Alice: Such a big piece is hard to light.
Shure: 应该还行
Shure: It should be fine.
Katrina: YOLO目标检测模型
Katrina: YOLO object detection model.
Tasha: 鸡蛋呢
Tasha: Where are the eggs?
Alice:不太好印
Alice: Hard to print.
Alice:我拿点纸箱
Alice: I'll get some cardboard.
Tasha: 拿3个鸡蛋
Tasha: Get 3 eggs.
Lucia: 我来我离得近
Lucia: I'll do it, I'm closer.
Tasha: 好那你来打吧
Tasha: Okay, then you crack them.
Alice:哦酒精棉是吗
Alice: Oh, alcohol wipes, right?
Lucia: 我害怕我会像那天那样打吗
Lucia: I'm scared I'll mess up like last time.
Lucia: 你你来打吧要不
Lucia: Maybe you should do it.
Alice:干的
Alice: Got it.
Lucia: 哦因为你戴着那个手套
Lucia: Oh, because you're wearing those gloves.
Shure: 像是硝酸那味
Shure: Smells like nitric acid.
Lucia: 但是我怕我不会打
Lucia: But I'm afraid I can't do it.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 就那天不是打错过一次
Lucia: Didn't I mess it up once last time?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
Alice:嗯好臭啊
Alice: Ugh, it stinks.
Tasha: 打这个碗里
Tasha: Crack it into the bowl.
Jake:好人类早期打蛋行为
Jake: Early human egg-cracking behavior.
Shure: 类似于安岩什么的东西
Shure: Like something from An Yan.
Tasha: 不要碰到水
Tasha: Don't let it touch the water.
Shure: 然后拿个小纸壳演传递圣火
Shure: Then take a small piece of paper and act like you're passing the Olympic torch.
Tasha: 打滴滴滴滴
Tasha: Crack it, crack it.
Tasha: 再滴再滴
Tasha: Crack it again.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 就是小心蛋黄不能破
Lucia: Be careful not to break the yolk.
Alice:拽两下呗
Alice: Pull it twice.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 第一次就成功了
Lucia: You got it on the first try.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Lucia: 要不还是你来吧
Lucia: Maybe you should still do it.
Shure: 撕撕你这撕这么大干啥你说
Shure: Why did you tear it so big? What are you doing?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我我拿着一个
Lucia: Haha, I'm holding one.
Jake:好看我的成功几个
Jake: Alright, see my successful ones.
Lucia: 你那个啥
Lucia: Yours...
Lucia: 这个要很小心的
Lucia: You have to be very careful with this.
Alice:这点够吗
Alice: Is this enough?
Shure: 够了够了
Shure: That's enough.
Jake:还行吧
Jake: Not bad.
Jake:感觉碰到了一下问题不大
Jake: I think it touched a bit, but it's fine.
Lucia: 我解决问题的方式回避问题
Lucia: My way of solving problems is avoiding them.
Jake:我来给你跟拍
Jake: I'll follow you with the camera.
Tasha: 把这个还是拿到楼上冰箱冷藏
Tasha: Let's still put this in the upstairs fridge.
Jake:没了
Jake: Done.
Lucia: 好的 10分钟吗
Lucia: Okay, 10 minutes?
Tasha: OK对
Tasha: OK, right.
Jake:那要不
Jake: How about...
Tasha: 就等这边完事了
Tasha: We wait until this side is done.
Tasha: 那边就可以开始了
Tasha: Then we can start over there.
Lucia: 行好的
Lucia: Okay, sounds good.
Jake:哎有有
Jake: Hey, there's something.
Lucia: 看看这这能放下不
Lucia: Check if this can fit here.
Jake:有个球
Jake: There's a ball.
Lucia: 这好哎
Lucia: This is good.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me check.
Shure: 火星不够
Shure: Not enough Mars.
Lucia: 算了还是放楼上吧
Lucia: Never mind, let's put it upstairs.
Katrina: 这可以吗
Katrina: Is this okay?
Katrina: 这可以也可以
Katrina: This is also fine.
Alice:有酒精
Alice: There's alcohol.
Katrina: 这如果要放的话
Katrina: If we want to place it here...
Shure: 有酒精吗咱们
Shure: Do we have alcohol?
Katrina: 就得把这架子重新倒腾一下
Katrina: We need to rearrange this shelf.
Jake:呃有
Jake: Uh, we do.
Katrina: 我看看楼上吧
Katrina: I'll check upstairs.
Jake:呃哎
Jake: Uh, hey.
Jake:有酒精吗
Jake: Do we have alcohol?
Katrina: 如果楼上东西不多的话应该能放下
Katrina: If there's not much stuff upstairs, it should fit.
Jake:你问问诺亚
Jake: Ask Noah.
Jake:他不知道
Jake: He doesn't know.
Jake:他之前买了消毒用的
Jake: He bought some for disinfection before.
Shure: 没事那也行
Shure: It's fine, that works too.
Jake:你问问看用
Jake: Ask him if we can use it.
Shure: 只要是酒精就行
Shure: As long as it's alcohol, it's fine.
Alice:这个引碳引到啥时候去
Alice: How long are we going to keep igniting the charcoal?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Shure: 路亚
Shure: Lua.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Shure: 你是不是有酒精来着
Shure: Do you have any alcohol?
Lucia: 我没有酒精
Lucia: I don't have alcohol.
Lucia: 我只有碘伏
Lucia: I only have iodine.
Shure: 啊那那那记
Shure: Ah, then that won't work.
Alice:烧不起来
Alice: It won't burn.
Shure: 我们最高度数的酒就是朗姆了
Shure: The highest proof alcohol we have is rum.
Lucia: 最高度数的应该是咱楼上那个百家德
Lucia: The highest proof should be the Baijia upstairs.
Shure: 那也不够烧的
Shure: That's still not enough to burn.
Jake:咋整呢
Jake: What should we do?
Shure: 再再次引一次
Shure: Try igniting it again.
Lucia: 呃这也放不下
Lucia: Uh, this won't fit either.
Shure: 有火吗主要咱没火
Shure: Do we have any fire? The main issue is we don't have fire.
Jake:谢斌如不在是吧哈哈
Jake: Shie Binru isn't here, right? Haha.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Oh no.
Shure: 对昨天应该把他火顺来的
Shure: Yeah, we should have brought some fire yesterday.
Lucia: 这咋整
Lucia: What should we do?
Alice:所以我们的火是啥
Alice: So, what's our fire source?
Shure: 我的火就是煤气罐
Shure: My fire source is the gas tank.
Alice:啊
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 不是燃气灶
Shure: Not the gas stove.
Shure: 就是我们的火
Shure: That's our fire source.
Alice:要不直接拿个碳在上面烧
Alice: Why don't we just use some charcoal to burn on top?
Lucia: 这玩意还能喝吧
Lucia: Can you even drink this stuff?
Shure: 再搞一次吧
Shure: Let's try again.
Lucia: 昨天打开的
Lucia: It was opened yesterday.
Alice:会中毒吗
Alice: Will it be toxic?
Shure: 运送火种
Shure: Transporting the fire source.
Jake:给你挡着有用吗
Jake: Does it help if I block it for you?
Jake:有点用吗
Jake: Does it help a bit?
Shure: 走慢点走就行
Shure: Just walk slowly, that's fine.
Shure: 别把这窗帘撂着就行
Shure: Just don't let the curtain catch fire.
Shure: 又他妈中
Shure: Damn, hit it again.
Shure: 中到崩出了
Shure: It hit and bounced out.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 再来我就不信了
Shure: Let's do it again, I don't believe it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这就先放楼下吧
Lucia: Let's put this downstairs first.
Lucia: 要不然楼上放不下了
Lucia: Otherwise, there's no room upstairs.
Lucia: 呃靠
Lucia: Ugh, damn.
Lucia: 楼下也放不下
Lucia: There's no room downstairs either.
Shure: 哨哨哨哨哨哨来来来
Shure: Whistle, whistle, whistle, come on.
Shure: 对我们可以把线
Shure: Yeah, we can put the wire...
Shure: 卧槽直接点
Shure: Whoa, just light it directly.
Shure: 直接放进去点
Shure: Just put it in and light it.
Jake:大成功
Jake: Big success!
Jake:是大成功吗
Jake: Was it a big success?
Lucia: 今天是要做什么呢
Lucia: What are we going to do today?
Shure: 应该成功了点
Shure: It should have succeeded a bit.
Jake:应该成功
Jake: It should have worked.
Tasha: 呃伯爵红茶
Tasha: Uh, Earl Grey tea.
Tasha: 芒果再搞点芒果吧
Tasha: Let's add some more mango.
Shure: 刚才那夹呢
Shure: Where's that clip just now?
Katrina: 哇那个我们学校卖可贵了
Katrina: Wow, it’s so expensive at our school.
Tasha: 注意下注意下注意
Tasha: Be careful, be careful, pay attention.
Shure: 夹去哪了
Shure: Where did the clip go?
Shure: 这是什么助燃剂我记得
Shure: What kind of accelerant is this, I remember.
Shure: 怎么着都能烧着应该
Shure: It should burn no matter what.
Jake:我也来点一点
Jake: Let me light a bit too.
Jake:烧纸烧纸这玩意我会
Jake: Burning paper, I can do this.
Jake:烧锅
Jake: Burning the stove.
Lucia: 需要先用两块纸烧一烧吗
Lucia: Do we need to burn two pieces of paper first?
Lucia: 还是直接用这个
Lucia: Or just use this directly?
Alice:感觉我会太我感觉会太慢了
Alice: I feel like it will be too slow.
Shure: 点着你就塞塞他
Shure: Light it and just stuff it in.
Alice:直接拿炭烧吧
Alice: Just burn it with charcoal.
Shure: 塞他底下
Shure: Stuff it underneath.
Jake:火光四起
Jake: Flames everywhere.
Alice:的通好风
Alice: Ventilate well.
Alice:别一会给大家整一氧化碳中毒了
Alice: Don't let everyone get carbon monoxide poisoning.
Shure: 把那夹子要回来
Shure: Get that clip back.
Lucia: 不会的
Lucia: It won't happen.
Shure: 哦这样也行
Shure: Oh, this works too.
Shure: 那边着了
Shure: It's burning over there.
Shure: 应该没事
Shure: It should be fine.
Jake:着了着了火了火了
Jake: It's burning, it's on fire.
Shure: 着了着
Shure: It's burning.
Shure: 了着了
Shure: 可以了走吧
Shure: It's fine, let's go.
Shure: 我说那边着了已经
Shure: I said it's burning over there already.
Shure: 他也着了
Shure: It's burning too.
Shure: 他解招了
Shure: He’s breaking free.
Alice:太好了直接扔里吧
Alice: Great, just throw it in directly.
Alice:给他扒拉进去
Alice: Push it in.
Alice:你这不把他扒拉进去吗
Alice: Aren't you going to push it in?
Shure: 他他夹不动了
Shure: He can't hold it anymore.
Shure: 已经脆了这个
Shure: It's already brittle.
Shure: 这烧塑料
Shure: This is burning plastic.
Shure: 而且这条都是塑料
Shure: And this whole thing is plastic.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's nothing we can do.
Jake:我再想想
Jake: Let me think about it.
Lucia: 咱们那个一次性的那个勺还还在吗
Lucia: Do we still have those disposable spoons?
Jake:我觉得在感觉是我放哪去了
Jake: I think we do, I feel like I put them somewhere.
Lucia: 为什么民宿里会没勺
Lucia: Why doesn't the guesthouse have spoons?
Lucia: 总感觉有哪里怪怪的
Lucia: It feels kind of odd.
Lucia: 应该有才对
Lucia: There should be some.
Lucia: 让我看看有没有什么别的原料
Lucia: Let me see if there are any other materials.
Lucia: 给您做一个
Lucia: I'll make you one.
Lucia: 充当一下
Lucia: Just to substitute.
Lucia: 鉴定完毕没有
Lucia: Are you done identifying it?
Shure: 狼烟起苍山
Shure: The smoke rises from the mountain.
Alice:我去
Alice: Oh my!
Tasha: 哦多了再煮一会
Tasha: Oh, cook it a bit longer.
Alice:一会会不会熏黑呀
Alice: Will it get smoked black?
Jake:难搞不定
Jake: It's hard to handle.
Jake:算了
Jake: Forget it.
Shure: 熏黑应该不至于
Shure: It shouldn't get smoked black.
Jake:硬核
Jake: Hardcore.
Alice:如今新新换的衣服
Alice: The new clothes we just changed into...
Lucia: 啊这有这有点大
Lucia: Ah, this is a bit big.
Alice:这一块面
Alice: This piece of dough...
Lucia: 洗一下吧
Lucia: Let's wash it.
Lucia: 这个好没咋用过
Lucia: This one hasn't been used much.
Jake:我我已经喝我已经喝到了
Jake: I... I've already drunk it.
Jake:我觉得挺好的
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:就当就就硬喝就
Jake: Just drink it hard.
Alice:借块
Alice: Borrow a piece.
Lucia: 哈哈你确定吗
Lucia: Haha, are you sure?
Lucia: 筷子也不需要来一个吗
Lucia: Don't you need a pair of chopsticks?
Jake:不用了不用了挺好的
Jake: No, no, it's fine.
Shure: 你怎么还想不开了呢
Shure: Why are you still so troubled?
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:这啥呀这怎么做的呀
Jake: What is this? How did you make it?
Jake:用鸡精调的呀
Jake: Did you use chicken essence?
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Yes, really.
Jake:真的真的吼吼
Jake: Really, really nice.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈笑死我了
Alice: Hahahahahahaha, I'm dying of laughter!
Jake:我看看你的小本本
Jake: Let me see your little notebook.
Shure: 哎倒也行你别说
Shure: Well, it works, don't you think?
Jake:红茶包红茶包
Jake: Black tea bags, black tea bags.
Jake:哪来的买的
Jake: Where did you buy them?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought them.
Tasha: 你觉得哪来的
Tasha: Where do you think they came from?
Jake:买的
Jake: Bought them.
Alice:是不是就是这样的
Alice: Is it like this?
Shure: 卧槽好像是
Shure: Damn, seems like it.
Shure: 好像是哎
Shure: Seems like it, huh.
Tasha: 林涵好聪明
Tasha: Lin Han is so smart.
Shure: 哦对
Shure: Oh yeah.
Shure: 他放在底下卧槽
Shure: He put it underneath, damn.
Jake:加3T蛋黄
Jake: Add 3T egg yolks.
Tasha: 3个吧
Tasha: Three of them, right?
Shure: 加大火势
Shure: Increase the heat.
Katrina: 这个这个东西好用吗
Katrina: Is this thing useful?
Shure: 来给我都给他烧了
Shure: Come on, let's burn it all.
Alice:晚上玩火会怎么尿床
Alice: Playing with fire at night will make you wet the bed.
Katrina: 尿床
Katrina: Wet the bed.
Shure: 尿炕
Shure: Wet the bed.
Lucia: 哇这是什么味道
Lucia: Wow, what's that smell?
Katrina: 是楼下那个烧炭火的
Katrina: It's from downstairs, they're burning charcoal.
Tasha: 怎么还是这么多呢
Tasha: Why is there still so much?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 我发现我衣服一直都没拿上来
Lucia: I realized I never brought my clothes up.
Lucia: 随便撂个地方吧
Lucia: Just drop them anywhere.
Jake:怎么回锅呢
Jake: How do you reheat it?
Jake:是哪一个呀
Jake: Which one is it?
Shure: 但说实话有点不够
Shure: But to be honest, it's kind of not enough.
Lucia: 嗯这都还有水不知道大家还喝不喝
Lucia: Hmm, there's still water, I wonder if anyone will drink it.
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Jake:在哪呢 30克
Jake: Where is it? 30 grams.
Shure: 但没有关系
Shure: But it's okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, oh.
Katrina: 什么东西
Katrina: What is it?
Lucia: 早晨的这个水要倒掉
Lucia: The morning water needs to be poured out.
Jake:80毫升的牛奶给运煮到30克是吗
Jake: 80ml of milk, boil it down to 30 grams, right?
Lucia: 这个这个应该是新杯哎
Lucia: This, this should be a new cup.
Shure: 都快着了吧
Shure: It's almost ready, right?
Lucia: 这这几个呢
Lucia: What about these few?
Katrina: 行啊
Katrina: Okay.
Tasha: 对就是要把它们浓缩掉
Tasha: Yes, we need to condense them.
Jake:那明白了
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 我感觉没有
Lucia: I don't think so.
Jake:明白
Jake: Understood.
Shure: 哎对
Lucia: 这应该也是新杯子
Lucia: This should also be a new cup.
Tasha: 是这么炼的
Tasha: This is how it's refined.
Jake:就是就是是
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Jake:炼乳啊那个
Jake: Condensed milk, that one.
Shure: 火化炉是不是不够了加
Shure: Is the cremator not hot enough?
Jake:那种很甜的那种酱你知道吧
Jake: That very sweet sauce, you know?
Tasha: 啊对就是那个
Tasha: Ah, yes, that one.
Lucia: 算了不关
Lucia: Forget it, doesn't matter.
Jake:就就就是这种就这么整烧出来的吗
Jake: So, is it made just like this?
Tasha: 就是这么烧出来的
Tasha: Yes, it's made this way.
Shure: 非常符合我们的环保理念
Shure: It aligns perfectly with our environmental philosophy.
Tasha: 呃好可以是
Tasha: Uh, okay, yes.
Shure: 就哭哭烧
Shure: Just keep burning it.
Shure: 这烫不烫
Shure: Is this hot?
Tasha: 完了又少了
Tasha: Oh no, it's less again.
Jake:那咋办
Jake: What should we do?
Tasha: 少了没有办法
Tasha: If it's less, there's nothing we can do.
Tasha: 味道浓一些
Tasha: Make the flavor stronger.
Shure: 别给他盖聂了
Shure: Don't cover it.
Shure: 不能吧应该
Shure: It shouldn't be, right?
Alice:收起来
Alice: Put it away.
Jake:你上回说的你要搞
Jake: Last time you said you wanted to get
Jake:几个这种彩票款
Jake: a few of these lottery types.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn it.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Jake:你不是说想搞几个彩票款
Jake: Didn't you say you wanted to get a few lottery types?
Jake:彩票款吗
Jake: Lottery types?
Jake:看谁能吃到
Jake: See who can eat it.
Tasha: 算了呃那个打蛋器呃盆
Tasha: Forget it, uh, the whisk, uh, the bowl.
Tasha: 对就是那个盆啊
Tasha: Yes, that bowl.
Lucia: 呃上次用的那个
Lucia: Uh, the one we used last time.
Tasha: 就是你刚冷冻起来的那个
Tasha: Is it the one you just froze?
Shure: 应该
Shure: Probably.
Lucia: 哦get it
Lucia: Oh, got it.
Shure: 都着了吧这碳
Shure: The charcoal is all lit, right?
Tasha: 哎还有一个呢
Tasha: Hey, there's still one more.
Shure: 还没着吗
Shure: It's not lit yet?
Alice:没反应呢
Alice: No reaction yet.
Alice:经过我们的不懈努力
Alice: After all our hard work,
Alice:这个炭终于受了一点皮外伤
Alice: this charcoal finally got a little scratch.
Katrina: 明天就跳跳舞是吧
Katrina: So we're just dancing tomorrow, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 然后明天要压花了
Katrina: And pressing flowers tomorrow.
Shure: 这算是着了吧
Shure: Does this count as being lit?
Katrina: 要不然来不及
Katrina: Otherwise, we won't make it in time.
Jake:压压花跳跳舞划划水
Jake: Press flowers, dance, and swim.
Alice:没火星还是那半截烧着呢
Alice: No sparks, just that half-burned part.
Katrina: 对对对明天买
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, buy it tomorrow.
Shure: 这还是那半家烧的
Shure: It's still that half burnt.
Tasha: 少了一个这个
Tasha: Missing one of these.
Katrina: 明天买下美文纸和旺仔牛
Katrina: Tomorrow we'll buy some beautiful paper and some milk.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:要不就给那个燃气炉上烧它得了
Alice: Or just burn it on the gas stove.
Jake:做做早饭
Jake: Make breakfast.
Lucia: 哎奇怪我找找看
Lucia: Hmm, strange, I'll check.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:这火还没那个
Alice: The fire isn't even...
Lucia: 嗯有没有可能
Lucia: Hmm, is it possible...
Shure: 一根一根烧
Shure: Burn one by one.
Alice:那其实烧够两三根
Alice: Actually, burn two or three.
Katrina: 几天我想想
Katrina: Let me think for a few days.
Jake:等快递整整理整理
Jake: Wait for the delivery, organize it.
Katrina: 明天是星期五了
Katrina: Tomorrow is Friday.
Lucia: 在在在在楼上呢
Lucia: It's upstairs.
Jake:明天星期五了
Jake: Tomorrow is Friday.
Alice:用其他印就行了
Alice: Use other prints, it's fine.
Jake:星期六整理整理拿到了
Jake: Organize it, get it on Saturday.
Lucia: 这个不是吧
Lucia: This isn't it, right?
Shure: 其实最快的方法就是加酒精
Shure: Actually, the fastest way is to add alcohol.
Katrina: 那今天晚上就
Katrina: Then tonight we...
Katrina: 明天必须压了
Katrina: We must press it tomorrow.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Katrina: 那我等会压一下
Katrina: Then I'll press it later.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 楼家要是没有我就再上楼看一下
Lucia: If the Lou family doesn't have it, I'll go upstairs and check again.
Shure: 最快的方法就是加酒精啊
Shure: The fastest way is to add alcohol.
Katrina: 时间过得可真快
Katrina: Time sure flies.
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯啊好的
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Alice:讲什么没听清
Alice: What did you say? I didn't hear clearly.
Jake:划划水就划完了
Jake: Just paddle around and it's done.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Shure: 我们有特别特别高浓度的酒精吗
Shure: Do we have very, very high concentration alcohol?
Jake:特别
Jake: Very.
Jake:特别高的
Jake: Very high.
Katrina: 特别特别的
Katrina: Extremely.
Jake:什么卧槽
Jake: What the heck?
Shure: 浓度的酒精
Shure: High concentration alcohol.
Alice:哦加酒精
Alice: Oh, add alcohol.
Jake:多高啊要干啥
Jake: How high? What are we doing?
Shure: 75那种
Shure: 75% type.
Lucia: 助燃吧
Lucia: To help it burn.
Shure: 对就是助燃
Shure: Yes, to help it burn.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:烧不起来是吧
Jake: It won't burn, right?
Jake:喝完了还行
Jake: It'll be fine after drinking.
Lucia: 还挺干净
Lucia: It's quite clean.
Alice:有酒精吗
Alice: Do we have alcohol?
Lucia: 来我帮你
Lucia: Let me help you.
Jake:还行
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 我我刚好帮你洗了
Lucia: I just happened to wash it for you.
Jake:哦谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
Lucia: 因为我这个也要洗
Lucia: Because I need to wash this too.
Alice:要不喷点油得了
Alice: Why not spray some oil?
Shure: 喷点油得了
Shure: Just spray some oil.
Jake:那我看看火去
Jake: Then I'll check the fire.
Shure: 油也不行吧
Shure: Oil won't work either, right?
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:给这摊上喷点油
Alice: Spray some oil on this spot.
Alice:让他烧着
Alice: Let it burn.
Shure: 你给他又加回来的是吗
Shure: Did you add him back again?
Shure: 还是说他一直在这呢
Shure: Or has he always been here?
Alice:没他就在这上边呢
Alice: No, he's been up here.
Jake:刷不完吗
Jake: Can't finish brushing?
Jake:烧烧 不起来吗
Jake: Can't it burn?
Lucia: 总感觉这勺子可以留一下
Lucia: I always feel this spoon can be kept.
Alice:这探看起来也就受了点皮外伤
Alice: It looks like he only got some minor injuries.
Tasha: 你能帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me out?
Lucia: 要不放旁边吧
Lucia: Or just put it aside.
Shure: 确实没浇透
Shure: Yeah, it's not soaked through.
Jake:哦要大酒精
Jake: Oh, we need more alcohol.
Tasha: 可以帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me out?
Jake:那给你买一个呗
Jake: Then let's buy one for you.
Lucia: 嗯你说
Lucia: Yeah, tell me.
Jake:让他4020分钟再到
Jake: Make him wait for another 40-20 minutes.
Jake:40分钟再到
Jake: 40 minutes more.
Shure: 就最快最快的酒精
Shure: The fastest alcohol.
Shure: 你就搜酒精
Shure: Just search for alcohol.
Shure: 然后最好20分钟就能到那种
Shure: Ideally, it should arrive in 20 minutes.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake:我给你搜一个美团
Jake: I'll search for it on Meituan.
Alice:喷点油行吗
Alice: Can we spray some oil?
Shure: 对美团
Shure: Yeah, Meituan.
Shure: 油够呛真够呛
Shure: Oil is really not suitable.
Tasha: 加75克糖
Tasha: Add 75 grams of sugar.
Shure: 或者买药那块
Shure: Or buy it from a pharmacy.
Shure: 最快的应该
Shure: That's probably the fastest.
Tasha: and 0.5的茶
Tasha: And 0.5 teaspoons of tea.
Tasha: 3个蛋黄
Tasha: 3 egg yolks.
Lucia: 这个碗里没有油就是好洗
Lucia: This bowl is easy to wash since it has no oil.
Shure: 综合排序
Shure: Sort by comprehensive order.
Tasha: 75克柠檬
Tasha: 75 grams of lemon.
Shure: 速度优先
Shure: Priority on speed.
Shure: 卧槽 30是最快
Shure: Damn, 30 minutes is the fastest.
Lucia: 15克糖
Lucia: 15 grams of sugar.
Shure: 行先整一瓶吧
Shure: Alright, let's get a bottle first.
Jake:看30分钟
Jake: Look, 30 minutes.
Jake:是他先到还是你先着是吧
Jake: Will he arrive first or will you light it first?
Shure: 先他先
Shure: He'll be first.
Shure: 着还是他先到吧
Shure: He'll arrive first.
Tasha: 是按一下清零
Tasha: Press once to reset.
Shure: 咱们最起码得吃上啊是吧
Shure: At the very least, we need to eat, right?
Lucia: 放上去按一下清铃是吗
Lucia: Put it on and press once to reset, right?
Alice:yeah
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's done.
Tasha: 这是不是有点太小了
Tasha: Isn't this a bit too small?
Lucia: 有可能我们要不倒多少
Lucia: Maybe we shouldn't pour too much.
Tasha: 分两次
Tasha: Do it in two times.
Lucia: 然后取对取下来再那个什么
Lucia: Then take it down and then...
Lucia: 你是刚好要加两次吗
Lucia: Are you going to add it twice?
Tasha: 我要加三次
Tasha: I need to add it three times.
Tasha: 那你倒35克先
Tasha: First pour 35 grams.
Tasha: 然后剩下的你再倒35
Tasha: Then pour another 35 grams.
Lucia: 34.8可以吗
Lucia: Is 34.8 grams okay?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yes, it's fine.
Jake:啥事
Jake: What's up?
Shure: 油烟机的事
Shure: It's about the range hood.
Alice:我刚才是应该是
Alice: I think I was supposed to...
Lucia: 刚才是35
Lucia: It was 35 grams just now.
Tasha: 三十五
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Lucia: 那这个这个是要到多少
Lucia: So how much should this be?
Katrina: 那这个这个啊
Katrina: So this, this...
Tasha: 四十啊
Tasha: Forty grams.
Jake:谢文柱咱吃的到
Jake: We'll have it, Wen Zhu.
Lucia: 直接到40啊
Lucia: Just pour it up to 40 grams.
Shure: 心如过来今晚上
Shure: Xinru is coming tonight.
Jake:他说他过
Jake: He said he's coming.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure: 放放这边
Shure: Put it over here.
Jake:我也要玩啊
Jake: I want to play too.
Lucia: 40克
Lucia: 40 grams.
Jake:打发是吧
Jake: Whipping, right?
Tasha: 好你来
Tasha: Alright, you do it.
Jake:好你从哪找这样的
Jake: Where did you find this?
Lucia: 26.8
Lucia: 26.8 grams.
Jake:另一个啊
Jake: Another one.
Jake:另一个那个
Jake: The other one.
Jake:哎少在这小的
Jake: Oh, not this small one.
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: Guess.
Lucia: 29.9
Lucia: 29.9 grams.
Jake:凑30是吗
Jake: So, 30 right?
Tasha: 40啊
Tasha: 40!
Lucia: 40差不多
Lucia: 40 is about right.
Shure: 我觉得这样就可以
Shure: I think this is good.
Tasha: 好差不多来
Tasha: Alright, close enough.
Lucia: 外面那点不管他
Lucia: Don't worry about that outside.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 全弄着有希望了
Shure: If we handle everything, there's hope.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:这么多数字我用几
Jake: With so many numbers, which one should I use?
Shure: 还好今天风是往那边刮
Shure: Good thing the wind is blowing that way today.
Shure: 不然呼呼全刮家里了
Shure: Otherwise, it'd all blow into the house.
Tasha: 拉到最大就行哎呦
Tasha: Just pull it to the max, oh dear.
Alice:哈哈没事
Alice: Haha, it's okay.
Jake:哈哈哈你不是说拉到最大就行
Jake: Hahaha, didn't you say to pull it to the max?
Alice:家里没啥窗户就封着的
Alice: The house doesn't have many windows, just sealed up.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你猜
Lucia: Hahaha, you guess.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 好好来吧
Tasha: Alright, let's go.
Shure: 也是是哪个倒没
Shure: Which one didn't fall?
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: Me.
Shure: 咱开窗我能告诉他关上吗
Shure: If we open the window, can I tell him to close it?
Lucia: 你猜我那天裤子上奶油是怎么奔上的
Lucia: Guess how the cream got on my pants that day.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Alice:那是
Alice: That's right.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Come on.
Shure: 啊那是那谁
Shure: Ah, that was, who was it?
Jake:有点突然
Jake: That was sudden.
Tasha: 雨露均沾一下
Tasha: Share the wealth a bit.
Alice:没事风没往那边吹
Alice: It's okay, the wind isn't blowing that way.
Jake:好哎好玩
Jake: Alright, this is fun.
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Rain Xuan.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Rain Xuan.
Shure: 你是不是住这个楼上
Shure: Do you live upstairs in this building?
Shure: 就是阳阁楼上
Shure: The one above the sunny attic.
Shure: 你把那个窗户关上
Shure: Can you close that window?
Katrina: 窗户关上
Katrina: Close the window.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure: 感觉这次应该可以
Shure: I think this time it should work.
Shure: 都找进来了
Shure: Everything's been found.
Shure: 这算找下来吗
Shure: Does this count as finding it?
Shure: 这没算找下来
Shure: This doesn't count as finding it.
Jake:是这么回事吧
Jake: Is that how it is?
Tasha: 停了加最后一次糖吧
Tasha: Stop and add the last bit of sugar.
Lucia: 我不知道要问威威
Lucia: I don't know, you should ask Tasha.
Tasha: 加最后一次糖
Tasha: Add the last bit of sugar.
Lucia: 谁
Lucia: Who?
Tasha: 停停加最后一次糖
Tasha: Stop, stop, add the last bit of sugar.
Shure: 不行啊
Shure: No, it won't work.
Alice:用大块碳爆炸
Alice: Use a big chunk of charcoal to explode it.
Tasha: 你看呃要
Tasha: You see, uh, do you want to...
Tasha: 嗯嗯行没事
Tasha: Mm-hmm, okay, it's fine.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 到现在还就那一块呢
Shure: Up till now, it's still just that one piece.
Shure: 是不
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 叫
Tasha: Call...
Shure: 他别灭了
Shure: Don't let it go out.
Shure: 他他妈还灭了
Shure: Damn, it went out.
Jake:他为什么能打起来啊
Jake: Why did it start fighting?
Shure: 别一会酒精来了我们火没了
Shure: Don't let the alcohol come and extinguish our fire.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:不是没有这个可能
Alice: It's not impossible.
Tasha: 有点打的过了
Tasha: It's a bit overdone.
Shure: 你都没放孜
Shure: You didn't even add cumin.
Jake:这个是挺
Jake: This is quite...
Jake:什么什么叫打过啊
Jake: What do you mean overdone?
Jake:这还能打过呢
Jake: How can it be overdone?
Jake:太硬了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, never mind.
Tasha: 加85克这个这个嗯
Tasha: Add 85 grams of this, this, um...
Shure: 油放了蚝油也放了
Shure: Oil is added, oyster sauce is added.
Jake:排练一下
Jake: Let's rehearse.
Jake:最后一天我好好打
Jake: I'll do it properly on the last day.
Shure: 但酱油没有
Shure: But no soy sauce.
Lucia: 85克呃这个这是什么呀
Lucia: 85 grams of, uh, this, what is this?
Shure: 酱油我以为不用放
Shure: I thought we didn't need soy sauce.
Tasha: 你可以先倒40克
Tasha: You can pour 40 grams first.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Lucia: 耶刚好
Lucia: Yay, perfect timing.
Shure: 我妈远程通过看我
Shure: My mom is watching me remotely.
Tasha: 茶包
Tasha: Teabag.
Shure: 这晌告诉我什么放的少了
Shure: She just told me that I added too little of something.
Katrina: 你妈这能看出来
Katrina: Your mom can tell?
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Katrina: 你刚那平板的充电宝呢
Katrina: Where's the charger for the tablet you just had?
Shure: 我跟我妈
Shure: My mom and I...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:哦哦哦你妈给你指导的是吧
Jake: Oh, your mom is giving you instructions, right?
Lucia: 第二回放多少 20还是25
Lucia: How much for the second round, 20 or 25?
Shure: 对远程指导
Shure: Yeah, remote instructions.
Jake:哦可以可以
Jake: Oh, that works.
Jake:为了不断为了不止于羞辱
Jake: To avoid continuous embarrassment...
Tasha: 都可以只要最后一共是85就行
Tasha: Both are fine as long as the total is 85.
Lucia: 一共85 刚才30啊
Lucia: A total of 85, earlier it was 30, right?
Shure: 那个呢
Shure: What about that one?
Jake:能放油吗
Jake: Can we add oil?
Lucia: 那还差50
Lucia: Still 50 short.
Jake:你这个火
Jake: Your fire...
Lucia: 那就那就2525行吗
Lucia: How about 25 and 25, is that fine?
Shure: 油肯定不能放吧
Shure: We definitely can't add oil, right?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: We can.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:助然嘛
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Katrina: 你妈说烧烤粉放少了
Katrina: Your mom said you added too little BBQ seasoning.
Alice:什么这么呛
Alice: Why is it so smoky?
Shure: 他说好看着
Shure: She said it's supposed to look good.
Shure: 因为正常好像他说是要放酱油的
Shure: Because normally, she said we need to add soy sauce.
Shure: 但是我忘记有这个
Shure: But I forgot about it.
Shure: 对然后就是靠酱油带带
Shure: Yeah, so we rely on soy sauce to give it color.
Jake:那就那还能
Jake: Then can we...
Jake:还能救吗
Jake: Can we still save it?
Shure: 不是一个是带色
Shure: One part is for color.
Shure: 再一个就是咸味嘛
Shure: Another part is for the salty taste.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 那就补补点这个呗
Shure: So we can add a bit of this.
Jake:补点吧可以
Jake: Add a bit, sure.
Lucia: 24.9
Jake:来上酱油
Jake: Come on, bring the soy sauce.
Shure: 酱油没有
Shure: We don't have soy sauce.
Shure: 咱们我以为不用
Shure: I thought we didn't need it.
Shure: 所以我就没买你知道吗
Shure: So I didn't buy it, you know?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那咋办呢放点盐
Jake: Then what do we do? Add some salt?
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 就是缺缺这个
Shure: We're just missing this.
Shure: 就补了点烧烤料就差不多
Shure: We can just add some barbecue seasoning, should be okay.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Jake:低配版问题不大
Jake: A low-budget version should be fine.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:为最后一天准备是吧
Jake: Preparing for the last day, right?
Shure: 80%还原了已经
Shure: It's already 80% similar.
Shure: 货不货
Shure: Is it done?
Lucia: 24.8行吗差的不OK
Lucia: 24.8, is that okay? It's not quite there.
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And that...
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 哇这个低筋粉用的还蛮快的咦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, we're going through this low-gluten flour pretty fast, huh?
Shure: 那个一会记得也呼了一下
Shure: Remember to call for that later.
Shure: 我再去看外面看看火
Shure: I'm going to check the fire outside.
Shure: 好火彻底灭了
Shure: The fire is completely out.
Shure: 哦你问问管家
Shure: Oh, ask the butler.
Jake:一点火星都不剩
Jake: Not a spark left.
Shure: 管家能不能帮忙送个酒精啥的
Shure: Ask the butler if he can bring some alcohol.
Shure: 应该有你快问一下酒精啥的
Shure: There should be some, just ask him quickly for some alcohol.
Shure: 反正最后一天也得用
Shure: We'll need it for the last day anyway.
Shure: 你问问管家有没有酒精
Shure: Just ask the butler if he has any alcohol.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 那个到哪了瞅一眼
Shure: Where is it? Let's take a look.
Shure: 点一下完成
Shure: Click to complete.
Shure: OK 9分钟39就能吃上了
Shure: OK, in 9 minutes and 39 seconds, we can eat.
Shure: 能吃上吧
Shure: Can we eat?
Lucia: 烤的时间比较久是吗
Lucia: It took a long time to roast, right?
Jake:这叫伯爵奶茶是吗
Jake: This is called Earl Grey milk tea, right?
Tasha: 油呢油呢哎油呢
Tasha: Where's the oil, where's the oil, hey, where's the oil?
Tasha: 哎这谁拿到这的
Tasha: Hey, who brought this here?
Alice:每件浅色衣服都逃不过
Alice: Every light-colored piece of clothing can't escape.
Shure: 拿点
Shure: Take some.
Tasha: 好能把搅一下吗
Tasha: Okay, can you stir it?
Tasha: 就是拿筷子搅一下
Tasha: Just use chopsticks to stir it.
Shure: 厨房湿巾在哪
Shure: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼上吗
Shure: Upstairs?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 等一下我那个
Lucia: Wait a second, my...
Lucia: 呃餐巾纸我拿一张
Lucia: Uh, I'll get a napkin.
Lucia: 要不然筷子板上来又没事
Lucia: Otherwise, the chopsticks on the board are fine.
Shure: 是胡椒的胡吗
Shure: Is it the pepper's "hu"?
Lucia: 等一下还没搅完
Lucia: Wait a second, I'm not done stirring.
Lucia: 搞完再弄一下
Lucia: Finish it up and stir a bit more.
Lucia: 是要大概搅到啥程度呀
Lucia: How much do I need to stir it?
Tasha: 融合就行
Tasha: Until it's blended.
Tasha: 没关系这里面还会再融的
Tasha: Don't worry, it will blend more inside.
Lucia: 啊这俩要要要融合可能要
Lucia: Ah, these two need to blend, maybe...
Shure: 把那个一会烤架给擦一下
Shure: Wipe the grill later.
Jake:这好融啊
Jake: This blends well.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 哈哈先把牛顿
Lucia: Haha, first Newton...
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么融化
Jake: Hahaha, how does this melt?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是这个这个原理是牛顿发现的
Lucia: But this principle was discovered by Newton.
Jake:不管他不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 不管他反正对
Lucia: Doesn't matter, anyway, yeah.
Jake:反正物理有物理的问题
Jake: Anyway, there are physics problems.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Right, right, right.
Lucia: 生物学有关的问题都归到牛顿头上
Lucia: All biological issues are Newton's problem.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 就脚就行了
Tasha: Just stir it.
Alice:擦完之后是不是还得洗
Alice: After wiping, do we need to wash it?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Alice:这上面可是洗洁精之类的那种东西
Alice: There's dish soap or something on it.
Tasha: 因为会打过
Tasha: Because it will be used.
Alice:你却也能吃肚子里
Alice: You might end up eating it.
Shure: 拿这个过来一下
Shure: Bring this over for a second.
Tasha: 应该没有问题了
Tasha: It should be fine now.
Jake:那为什么不能用他的那个一
Jake: Then why can't we use his...
Shure: 没问题真的
Shure: No problem, really.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:要不洗一下吧
Alice: How about we wash it?
Jake:他不是有好几档吗
Jake: Doesn't he have several settings?
Shure: 方便的话就冲一下
Shure: If it's convenient, just rinse it.
Tasha: 是的你真的很聪明
Tasha: Yes, you're really smart.
Shure: 因为这个基本就是干净的啊
Shure: Because this is basically clean.
Tasha: 要不你来
Tasha: How about you do it?
Shure: 确实稍微冲一下
Shure: Just give it a quick rinse.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Shure: 已经饿的不行了是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you starving already? Haha.
Tasha: 这是切蛋糕
Tasha: This is for cutting the cake.
Tasha: 的
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure: 卧槽有的着了居然有两块红了已经
Shure: Wow, some of them are burnt, two pieces are already red.
Alice:大的小的
Alice: Big ones or small ones?
Shure: 大的
Shure: Big ones.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Impressive.
Jake:这是切蛋糕的
Jake: This is for cutting the cake.
Lucia: 呃对那天微微解释一下他怎么用的
Lucia: Uh, yes, Tasha explained how to use it that day.
Lucia: 但是其实我也没搞明白
Lucia: But I still didn't quite get it.
Lucia: 反正总之就是这样用的
Lucia: Anyway, this is how you use it.
Jake:什么时候切
Jake: When do we cut it?
Tasha: 等会就切
Tasha: We'll cut it in a bit.
Tasha: 你要切吗
Tasha: Do you want to cut it?
Jake:我要切
Jake: I want to cut it.
Tasha: 好你切
Tasha: Okay, you cut it.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine it.
Jake:一点都想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine it at all.
Tasha: 你能帮我扶一下
Tasha: Can you help me hold it?
Tasha: 从这开始
Tasha: Start from here.
Lucia: 这个大概搅成什么样呀
Lucia: What should the texture be like?
Tasha: 就这样就行了
Tasha: This is good enough.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 只不过我这边还在压模具
Tasha: But I'm still pressing the mold.
Lucia: 嗯那我趁你压的时候接着搅搅
Lucia: Alright, I'll keep stirring while you press.
Shure: 那是哪个我再找找
Shure: Which one is it? I'll keep looking.
Shure: 行先放那就行
Shure: Alright, just leave it there.
Shure: 这还没没没咋地呢
Shure: It's not that big of a deal yet.
Shure: 放下说问题不大
Shure: Just leave it, it should be fine.
Alice:这桌干净的吗
Alice: Is this table clean?
Shure: 基本干净
Shure: Basically clean.
Tasha: 然后又
Tasha: And then...
Shure: 放了
Shure: Put it.
Shure: 有两块着了
Shure: There are two pieces that are lit.
Tasha: 要越高越好
Tasha: The higher the better.
Jake:哦那就有戏啊
Jake: Oh, then there's hope!
Tasha: 因为这样子可以减少它的气泡
Tasha: Because that way it can reduce the bubbles.
Alice:有戏对哪两花啊
Alice: Hope for which two flowers?
Shure: 游戏对最起码我火种没灭
Shure: At least my fire isn't out.
Tasha: 据说是这样子
Tasha: They say so.
Alice:先天打工圣体这是
Alice: This is the innate work body.
Shure: 他俩很着急
Shure: They're very anxious.
Tasha: 不知道做了几个人的量
Tasha: Don't know how much we made for how many people.
Shure: 然后我们还有一个非常重要素材就是
Shure: Then we have a very important material, which is...
Shure: 哦看到了看到了
Shure: Oh, I see it, I see it.
Alice:玩不上
Alice: Can't play.
Shure: 我是周一回来
Shure: I'll be back on Monday.
Jake:这就整完了
Jake: It's all done.
Jake:就剩烤了
Jake: Just left to bake.
Shure: 周日最后一天
Shure: Last day is Sunday.
Shure: 但这地好像租个周几我忘了
Shure: But I forgot which day we rented this place till.
Shure: 你周日可以来来吃吃喝喝玩玩
Shure: You can come on Sunday to eat, drink, and play.
Shure: 不你周日如果不去的话你就要来
Shure: No, if you don't go on Sunday, you have to come.
Shure: 因为我已经添上你的名字了
Shure: Because I've already added your name.
Jake:这是预热过的
Jake: It's preheated.
Jake:烤40分钟
Jake: Bake for 40 minutes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:就等着就行了嗯
Jake: Just wait, that's it.
Tasha: 然后再打发个奶油就行
Tasha: Then whip some cream.
Tasha: 但是奶油打发等它快烤出来再打就行
Tasha: But whip the cream when it's almost done baking.
Shure: 咱们最后一天是周一还是周日来着
Shure: Is our last day Monday or Sunday?
Jake:周日哎
Jake: Sunday, hey.
Tasha: 没事了
Tasha: It's fine now.
Tasha: 这个洗了等会打奶油用
Tasha: This is washed, we can use it to whip the cream later.
Lucia: 打奶
Lucia: Whip the cream.
Alice:打奶油
Alice: Whip the cream.
Alice:我洗个筷子
Alice: I'm going to wash some chopsticks.
Tasha: 嗯应该是吧
Tasha: Hmm, I think so.
Alice:去上个厕所
Alice: Going to the restroom.
Alice:先放一下
Alice: Let it sit for a while.
Shure: 配和你走到山顶
Shure: I'll accompany you to the top of the mountain.
Shure: 到骑手还有多久
Shure: How much longer until the rider arrives?
Shure: 是不是快到了
Shure: Are they almost here?
Jake:四分钟
Jake: Four minutes.
Shure: OK那我们一会保留一块活种
Shure: OK, then we'll keep a piece of live seed.
Shure: 然后把剩下的全浇上
Shure: And then pour the rest all over it.
Shure: 那什么然后拿他的这个热量把
Shure: Then use its heat to...
Shure: 那个酒精给引着
Shure: Ignite the alcohol.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Shure: 这个原理
Shure: That's the principle.
Jake:很make sense
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake:太合理了
Jake: Totally reasonable.
Shure: 对道理道理
Shure: Yeah, that's the logic.
Jake:当代牛顿
Jake: Modern-day Newton.
Shure: 都是这个道理
Shure: It's all about that logic.
Jake:当代爱因斯坦
Jake: Modern-day Einstein.
Shure: 他能不能着
Shure: Whether it lights up...
Shure: 那他是是他的造化了
Shure: That's up to fate.
Jake:还有再不能招
Jake: If it still doesn't light...
Jake:倒汽油有用吗
Jake: Will pouring gasoline help?
Shure: 汽油可以
Shure: Gasoline can work.
Jake:汽油可以这油不行
Jake: Gasoline works, this oil doesn't.
Shure: 汽油可以
Shure: Gasoline works.
Tasha: 现在开始哎
Tasha: Start now, hey.
Shure: 这个油肯定不行
Shure: This oil definitely doesn't work.
Shure: 你还有汽油啊
Shure: Do you still have gasoline?
Jake:我们没有汽油但是可以
Jake: We don't have gasoline, but we can...
Shure: 哈哈哈他有两块
Shure: Haha, he has two pieces.
Shure: 着了汽油你可以倒回家去
Shure: Once it's lit, you can take it home.
Jake:但是汽油你可以到换家借
Jake: But you can borrow some gasoline.
Shure: 哈哈我操
Shure: Haha, damn it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha: 所以是烤不开是吗
Tasha: So, it won't cook?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 点不着是吗
Tasha: It won't light up?
Shure: 马上找了
Shure: It'll light up soon.
Shure: 酒精马上到了
Shure: The alcohol is almost here.
Jake:哈哈还特地买了酒精
Jake: Haha, we even specially bought alcohol.
Shure: 你们可以出来
Shure: You guys can come out.
Shure: 就是布置布置这桌子
Shure: Just need to set up the table.
Shure: 马上就能吃了
Shure: We can eat soon.
Shure: 先把饼给你们画圆了
Shure: I'll draw the circles on the pancakes first.
Shure: 然后可以布置布置桌子了
Shure: Then we can set up the table.
Shure: 准备准备吃了
Shure: Get ready to eat.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:至少就是那个几块钱
Jake: At least it's just a few bucks.
Katrina: 去外面是吗
Katrina: Outside, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:半毛半毛新币
Jake: Half a dime in the new currency.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: I think so.
Jake:5毛新币
Jake: 5 cents in the new currency.
Lucia: 不记得了
Lucia: I don't remember.
Shure: 不行我也饿了得赶紧
Shure: No, I am hungry too, let's hurry up.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 但是你可以试试看
Lucia: But you can try it out.
Jake:简单的快乐
Jake: Simple joys.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 然后你把蛋糕放在这
Tasha: And then you put the cake here.
Tasha: 然后这样子过去
Tasha: Then you move it like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好等会你来展示
Tasha: Okay, you can show it later.
Jake:好的交给我吧
Jake: Alright, leave it to me.
Jake:我先切一个土豆试一试
Jake: I'll try cutting a potato first.
Tasha: 如果说你们想要切三层对吧
Tasha: If you want to cut three layers, right?
Tasha: 那那你可能就要在第一层
Tasha: Then you might need to cut the first layer,
Tasha: 第三层和最上面一层
Tasha: third layer, and the top layer.
Jake:嗯没问题
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 这样子就可以切出来
Tasha: This way it can be cut out.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:我先试试
Jake: I'll try first.
Tasha: 不是还要加芒果吗
Tasha: Aren't we adding mangoes too?
Tasha: 然后我们可以一层芒果夹心
Tasha: Then we can have a layer of mango filling.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 一层奶油夹心
Tasha: And a layer of cream filling.
Katrina: 啊好好吃
Katrina: Ah, it tastes so good.
Tasha: 然后一层草莓夹心等等
Tasha: Then a layer of strawberry filling, etc.
Jake:然后一层
Jake: And then a layer.
Jake:哦好好好
Jake: Oh, alright, alright.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:怎么做啊
Jake: How do we do this?
Jake:那就切草莓
Jake: Let's cut the strawberries.
Jake:切芒果的是吧
Jake: Are we cutting the mangoes too?
Tasha: 你不是说尽量把芒果消灭掉吗
Tasha: Didn't you say to get rid of the mangoes as much as possible?
Jake:就是就是把它切成碎
Jake: Yeah, just cut them into small pieces.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Tasha: 豆和巧克力豆夹心夹层
Tasha: Beans and chocolate chips in the layers.
Tasha: 所以大家要吃什么夹层
Tasha: So, what layers do you all want?
Tasha: 就夹什么夹层就行了
Tasha: Just add whatever layers you want.
Katrina: 天好幸福
Katrina: Oh, this is so wonderful.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow
Katrina: 芒果的芒
Katrina: Mango, the mango.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:芒果在这
Jake: The mango is here.
Jake:我要怎么准备它
Jake: How should I prepare it?
Tasha: 把皮削了
Tasha: Peel it.
Tasha: 然后你如果想吃大块的你就不切
Tasha: Then, if you want big pieces, don't cut it.
Tasha: 就直接一片一片的加进去
Tasha: Just add it in slices.
Jake:好我先去拿个酒精
Jake: Alright, let me get some alcohol first.
Tasha: 如果你想吃芒果丁你就全部都切成丁
Tasha: If you want mango cubes, cut it all into cubes.
Shure: 我还没叫呢
Shure: I haven't even called yet.
Alice:你就全部切成
Alice: Just cut it all into...
Jake:好嘞好好好没问题
Jake: Okay, okay, no problem.
Tasha: 敷衍
Tasha: So perfunctory.
Shure: 而且这个不嫌多
Shure: And it's not too much.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, how are you?
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know what?
Jake:好来了来了来了嘿
Jake: Alright, alright, here we go, hey.
Tasha: 嗯我要吃肉哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, I want to eat meat, haha.
Shure: 酱油料酒都得放
Shure: We need to add soy sauce and cooking wine.
Lucia: 那等一下
Lucia: Wait a minute.
Lucia: 他们应该很快就可以考了
Lucia: They should be able to bake soon.
Shure: 料酒少放
Shure: Add a little less cooking wine.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure: 酱油少那现在就是没有酱油
Shure: And less soy sauce. Now we don't have soy sauce.
Shure: 这个事情已经改变不了了
Shure: This can't be changed anymore.
Tasha: 一个蛋糕会不会太少了要不要在烤店
Tasha: One cake might not be enough. Should we bake another one?
Shure: 我怎么能补救一下
Shure: How can I fix this?
Tasha: 纸杯的反正也很简单
Tasha: The paper cup one is pretty simple anyway.
Shure: 我就多放了点那个烧烤料
Shure: I just added a bit more of that barbecue seasoning.
Lucia: 都可以你决定
Lucia: It’s up to you, you decide.
Jake:谢谢您再见
Jake: Thank you, goodbye.
Shure: 然后又稍微就多加了一点蚝油
Shure: And then I added a little more oyster sauce.
Tasha: 所以那天的量是10个的量
Tasha: So that day's amount was for 10 servings.
Tasha: 所以还是考10个就行了
Tasha: So just make 10 servings, that's enough.
Shure: 呼呼呼呼呼
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈来吧
Jake: Hahaha, come on.
Tasha: 超级简单这个
Tasha: This is super easy.
Shure: 又又买了什么
Shure: What did you buy again?
Shure: 勺子是吗
Shure: A spoon, right?
Lucia: 也可以如果如果
Lucia: It’s also okay if if...
Shure: 啊对咱没勺
Shure: Ah, we don't have a spoon.
Lucia: 今天晚上吃不
Lucia: Do we eat it tonight?
Lucia: 完的话
Lucia: If not...
Lucia: 冷藏到明天早上当早饭也可以是吗
Lucia: We can refrigerate it and have it for breakfast tomorrow, right?
Tasha: 可以吧
Tasha: Sure, I guess.
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 早说配勺的话配点酱油不就得了吗
Shure: If you had said we needed a spoon, couldn't we have just added some soy sauce?
Lucia: 不会那个什么
Lucia: It wouldn't...
Tasha: 嗯应该可以吧
Tasha: Hmm, it should be fine.
Tasha: 那只需要把这个擦干就行了
Tasha: We just need to wipe this dry.
Shure: 不就把这个问题
Shure: Won't that solve the problem
Shure: 酱油的问题也给解决了吗哈哈哈
Shure: of soy sauce too? Hahaha
Tasha: 然后我们嗯
Tasha: And then we, um...
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 完全看不见他的状态
Tasha: Can't see its condition at all.
Shure: 那个夹子去
Shure: Get the tongs.
Shure: 我怕直接把这个一撒再给它浇灭了
Shure: I'm afraid if I pour this directly, it will put out the fire.
Tasha: 我干错了我挑战一下他
Tasha: I made a mistake. I'll challenge him.
Shure: 哎那个碳夹呢
Shure: Hey, where are the charcoal tongs?
Shure: 我随手
Shure: I just...
Jake:当时一直没找着是吧
Jake: You still couldn't find them, right?
Shure: 不是我刚才找着这呢
Shure: No, I just found them here.
Shure: 直接放桌上
Shure: Put them on the table.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:没关系留点遗憾留个20%
Jake: It’s okay, leave some regrets, like 20%.
Tasha: 他已经
Tasha: He already...
Lucia: 哦这个太挨着上面了是吗
Lucia: Oh, is this too close to the top?
Shure: 这个成功
Shure: This worked.
Shure: 实验样本放在这边
Shure: Place the experiment sample here.
Tasha: 对所以哎呀完了有一张纸掉上去了
Tasha: Yes, so... Oh no, a piece of paper fell on it.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 拿筷子剪出来行吗
Lucia: Can we cut it out with chopsticks?
Tasha: 嗯可以我就感觉他太靠上了
Tasha: Hmm, sure. I just think it's too close to the top.
Shure: 浇上去
Shure: Pour it on.
Lucia: 哎刚刚用的那根筷子上哪去
Lucia: Hey, where did the chopstick we just used go?
Tasha: 所以想要挑
Tasha: So I want to pick it out.
Lucia: 是不是已经被洗了
Lucia: Was it already washed?
Lucia: 擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it.
Lucia: 要不要把底下这层撤了
Lucia: Should we remove the bottom layer?
Shure: 玩会尿炕啊
Shure: Playing with fire, huh?
Shure: 小朋友们切勿模仿
Shure: Kids, don't try this at home.
Lucia: 然后光放一层
Lucia: And just leave one layer.
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Whoa.
Tasha: 对我刚刚想的也是把它放在
Tasha: Yes, I was thinking of placing it...
Shure: 手上整的
Shure: In your hand.
Jake:为啥玩火尿炕
Jake:为为为什么呢
Jake: Why, why?
Tasha: 蛋糕雏形
Tasha: Cake shape.
Lucia: 拆一下
Lucia: Take it apart.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake:他给的那个出燃机是什么东西
Jake: What kind of fuel did he give?
Shure: 就是一个特别特别能烧的东西
Shure: Just something that burns really well.
Jake:一烧就没了
Jake: Burns up instantly.
Alice:酒精送到了
Alice: The alcohol is here.
Lucia: 多么甜蜜
Lucia: So sweet.
Jake:这味真大
Jake: It smells strong.
Jake:来我给你端酒精
Shure: 这个咱把这个整着了
Shure: Let's get this thing going.
Alice:酒精是不是送到了
Alice: Is the alcohol here?
Jake:到了
Jake: It's here.
Shure: 送到了
Shure: It's here.
Shure: 接着这个把这个先点着
Shure: Let's light this up first.
Tasha: 擦干就行
Tasha: Just wipe it dry.
Shure: 好像点不着他似的你要不
Shure: Seems like it won't light. Maybe you should...
Tasha: 继续准备一下原材料
Tasha: Continue preparing the raw materials.
Katrina: 继续往前走
Katrina: Keep moving forward.
Shure: 要不借着这个你再去
Shure: Why don't you take this and go again.
Shure: 那个屋里去
Shure: Go into that room.
Shure: 屋里再烧一下子
Shure: Burn it a bit more inside.
Shure: 对交给你了
Shure: Yeah, leave it to you.
Shure: 咱先等他静候他
Shure: Let's wait for him first.
Jake:咱是不是打个火
Jake: Should we light a fire?
Jake:买个火机是不是也挺好的哈哈哈
Jake: Buying a lighter would be nice too, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 就单核摘
Shure: Just single-core picking.
Shure: 单线程没有工人就是不行
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake:单细胞生物
Jake: Single-celled organism.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 我去我军手套只有最后一双了不戴了
Tasha: Oh no, my military gloves are down to the last pair, I won't wear them.
Alice:别吸了
Alice: Stop inhaling.
Shure: 草履虫只能进行一些简单的生命活动
Shure: Paramecium can only perform simple life activities.
Alice:来煽风点火了
Alice: Come and fan the flames.
Shure: 着了吗
Shure: Is it lit?
Jake:密码也只要7天就
Jake: The password only needs 7 days.
Shure: 对 3天才能记住
Shure: Yeah, it takes 3 days to remember.
Lucia: 好像可以了
Lucia: Looks like it's done.
Jake:我来切哦
Jake: I'll cut it, okay?
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:圣火来了
Alice: The sacred fire is coming.
Shure: 慢慢慢慢来慢慢来
Shure: Slowly, slowly, take it slow.
Shure: 再慢点再慢点再慢点OK
Shure: Even slower, even slower, okay.
Shure: 稳住稳住
Shure: Steady, steady.
Shure: 给他立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Katrina: 你最擅长
Katrina: You're the best at this.
Shure: 立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Jake:哎是为什么要打奶油是吗
Jake: Hey, why do we need to whip the cream?
Katrina: 哎是来
Katrina: Hey, come on.
Katrina: 为什么要打哎
Katrina: Why do we need to whip it, hey?
Lucia: 哎这个是还没洗是吧
Lucia: Hey, this one hasn't been washed, right?
Katrina: 这个是不是没洗
Katrina: This one hasn't been washed, right?
Shure: OK OK好好
Shure: OK, OK, good, good.
Katrina: 这个不用洗不用洗
Katrina: This one doesn't need to be washed.
Lucia: 这个不用洗不用洗
Lucia: This one doesn't need to be washed.
Tasha: 这个不用洗因为他还是放蛋黄
Tasha: This one doesn't need to be washed because it's still holding the egg yolk.
Alice:不许来风
Katrina: 因为他还是放弹幕嘛
Lucia: 哦行
Shure: 给他
Tasha: 让你打3个蛋你怎
Jake:这样好不行啊
Lucia: 补充点能量才能打得好
Jake:对对对打蛋得费劲呢
Alice:喷点酒精
Jake:打了打了
Shure: 直接浇灭
Alice:牛逼再来吧
Tasha: 这呢这呢
Jake:对不起对不起
Tasha: 无菌手套不够了不戴了我洗干净
Alice:还有没了
Katrina: 口红够了
Alice:我刚才见了这
Shure: 别一会酒精用没了卧槽
Lucia: 幸
Jake:嗯好谢谢
Jake: Hmm, okay, thanks.
Shure: 你们那边有没有百事可乐
Shure: Do you guys have Pepsi over there?
Shure: 有百事可乐
Shure: Got Pepsi.
Shure: 再放点百事
Shure: Add some Pepsi.
Shure: 百事可乐少放一点
Shure: Just a little bit of Pepsi.
Lucia: 哇好厉害啊
Lucia: Wow, impressive!
Shure: 鸡翅和这个蚝不要放多了
Shure: Don't add too much chicken wings and oysters.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 蚝放多了甜
Shure: Too many oysters will make it sweet.
Tasha: 打蛋是一门学问你学不来
Tasha: Beating eggs is an art, you can't learn it.
Katrina: 你学不来
Katrina: You can't learn it.
Lucia: 对我学不来哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, I can't learn it, hahaha.
Shure: 放了可乐都
Shure: Added all the Pepsi.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 我学不来
Tasha: I can't learn it.
Shure: 其他全放了
Shure: Added everything else.
Shure: 就酱油我以为不用呢
Shure: I thought we didn't need soy sauce.
Tasha: 我替他在说这句话
Tasha: I'm saying it for him.
Alice:圣火降临
Alice: The holy fire descends.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: the next
Tasha: The next.
Jake:哎我觉得
Jake: Hey, I think...
Lucia: 再再来一个是吧
Lucia: Let's do another one, right?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得还有两个赞嘛
Jake: Hahaha, I think there are two more likes.
Lucia: 我来
Lucia: I'll do it.
Alice:好好好怕爆炸哈哈
Alice: Okay, okay, I'm scared it might explode, haha.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia: 专注气氛组一万年
Lucia: Focus on the atmosphere team for ten thousand years.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Whoa, damn.
Lucia: 你这个会磕太厉害了
Lucia: You're going to knock it too hard.
Lucia: 小心哇这都没了哈哈
Lucia: Be careful, wow, this is gone, haha.
Jake:没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 天选打单人
Lucia: The chosen one plays solo.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:是这是逐步探索边界
Jake: Yes, this is gradually exploring the boundaries.
Alice:你可小心点
Alice: Be careful.
Katrina: 人
Katrina: People.
Alice:别别顺着你的皮烧着你了
Alice: Don't let it burn you.
Lucia: 他刚才超级强的磕了一下竟然弄没了
Lucia: He knocked it so hard earlier that he broke it.
Katrina: 我也听到了
Katrina: I heard it too.
Katrina: 我也会烂在手上
Katrina: I might break it too.
Tasha: 这个这个这个放到那个冷藏yes
Tasha: This, this, this, put it in the refrigerator, yes.
Lucia: 对OK
Lucia: Yeah, okay.
Alice:卧槽太爽了吧这
Alice: Whoa, this is so cool.
Lucia: 看一眼那可能还是得放到楼上去
Lucia: Take a look, it might still need to go upstairs.
Shure: 帅吧
Shure: Cool, right?
Tasha: 你可以把这个没事你去吧
Tasha: You can take this, it's fine, go ahead.
Shure: 此刻已成艺术
Shure: This moment has become art.
Alice:那那夹子呢
Alice: Where's the clip?
Lucia: 这个这个放在哪
Lucia: Where do I put this?
Lucia: 这已经擦好了
Lucia: This is already cleaned.
Tasha: 呃干的就放在这就行我觉得
Tasha: Uh, just put the dry one here, I think.
Alice:你夹子去哪了
Alice: Where did your clip go?
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:哎真好看
Jake: Hey, it looks great.
Shure: BB着了这不可能
Shure: BB, it's on fire, that's impossible.
Shure: 不着了吧这
Shure: Not on fire, right?
Alice:你夹子呢
Alice: Where's your clip?
Tasha: 这个擦一下这个
Tasha: Wipe this down.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Alice:那夹子
Alice: That clip.
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Shure: 那夹子我刚才随地扔到
Shure: I just threw that clip on the ground.
Jake:这个好
Jake: This is good.
Alice:哦我知道了
Alice: Oh, I get it.
Jake:哇起火了
Jake: Wow, it's on fire!
Jake:哇好开心
Jake: Wow, so happy.
Jake:看一眼烤一烤
Jake: Look at it, roast it a bit.
Shure: 看到了吗
Shure: Can you see it?
Jake:为什么这么牛逼
Jake: Why is it so awesome?
Shure: 因为酒精牛逼
Shure: Because alcohol is awesome.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Shure: 不会
Shure: It won't.
Alice:这俩腿打架啊
Alice: These two legs are fighting.
Shure: 酒精烧完了他都没烧吧
Shure: The alcohol burned out, it didn't burn, right?
Shure: 完了完了
Shure: It's over, it's over.
Jake:完了原来是纸的
Jake: Oh no, it's actually made of paper.
Alice:不耐烧
Alice: Not resistant to burning.
Shure: 实在烧实在烧了
Shure: It's really burning, it's really burning.
Jake:纸在烧我以为碳全烧起来了
Jake: The paper is burning, I thought all the charcoal caught fire.
Shure: 他们确实烧起来了
Shure: They indeed caught fire.
Jake:哦小烧起
Jake: Oh, a small flame.
Shure: 我们应该给底下垫一层纸壳
Shure: We should put a layer of cardboard underneath.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 然后纸壳一直在烧的话
Shure: And if the cardboard keeps burning...
Lucia: 没问题没问题
Lucia: No problem, no problem.
Shure: 他就应该可以拿回去干吧
Shure: It should be able to take it back then.
Tasha: 他怎么洗着洗着碗跑了呢
Tasha: How did he run off while washing the dishes?
Jake:那我们这么干吧
Jake: Then let's do it this way.
Lucia: 呃那是要洗啥呀我来
Lucia: Uh, what needs washing? I'll do it.
Jake:我们有足够的纸
Jake: We have enough paper.
Tasha: 这个洗干擦干就行
Tasha: Just wash this and dry it.
Katrina: which are reconnecting
Lucia: 洗
Lucia: Wash.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How's it going?
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's fine.
Tasha: 哇那我们可以开始吃了
Tasha: Wow, then we can start eating.
Lucia: 这不能用吧
Lucia: This can't be used, right?
Tasha: 哎他回来了哈哈
Tasha: Hey, he's back, haha.
Tasha: 交给您
Tasha: Over to you.
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: Your turn.
Tasha: 您愿意
Tasha: If you want.
Shure: 找一个够长的
Shure: Find one that's long enough.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 你来把它搅拌
Tasha: You stir it.
Shure: 这绝对够长拿一下
Shure: This is definitely long enough, here.
Tasha: 给你你从此学会烘焙
Tasha: Here, you'll learn baking from now on.
Shure: 你们现在都是古希腊掌管圣火的女神
Shure: You guys are now the Greek goddesses of the sacred fire.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 筷子帮您准备好了
Tasha: Chopsticks are ready for you.
Tasha: 完了就这样吧
Tasha: Alright, let's leave it at that.
Tasha: 开始把它充分搅拌
Tasha: Start mixing it thoroughly.
Tasha: 搅拌到完全融合
Tasha: Mix it until fully combined.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 真的可以
Tasha: It really works.
Lucia: 真的可以
Lucia: It really works.
Tasha: 这是真的可以
Tasha: It really works.
Lucia: 至少肉眼上完全了
Lucia: At least it looks complete.
Katrina: 这是酒精吗哪来的
Katrina: Is this alcohol? Where did it come from?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后这个怎么给他烧着呢卧槽
Shure: So how do we light it up? Damn.
Lucia: 就至少肉眼上可以
Lucia: At least it looks fine.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: It’s fine.
Tasha: 40克
Tasha: 40 grams.
Lucia: 40克
Lucia: 40 grams.
Tasha: 这用的太快了补个货
Tasha: We're using it up so fast, restock.
Katrina: 他们心应该是都着了
Katrina: Their hearts must be on fire.
Alice:这些明显就一点点
Alice: There’s just a little bit.
Tasha: 面粉哪都有
Tasha: There’s flour everywhere.
Shure: 累死了妈妈
Shure: I’m exhausted, mom.
Shure: 嘻嘻
Shure: Hehe.
Lucia: 嗯又灭了吗
Lucia: Hmm, did it go out again?
Shure: 就是不大信
Shure: I just don't believe it.
Alice:那个小子呢
Alice: Where's that guy?
Lucia: 他们又灭了
Lucia: They went out again.
Lucia: 咱今天晚上能吃上饭不
Lucia: Are we going to have dinner tonight?
Shure: 能哎呦
Shure: Yes, sure.
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Oh, you scared me!
Alice:那个酒精呢
Alice: Where's the alcohol?
Tasha: 哎呦哈哈
Tasha: Oh, haha!
Shure: 吓我一跳
Shure: You scared me!
Lucia: 哈哈哈行
Lucia: Hahaha, okay.
Shure: 不要质疑我
Shure: Don't doubt me.
Lucia: 有您这句话我就放心了
Lucia: With that, I'm reassured.
Alice:还有一点点火
Alice: There's still a bit of fire.
Tasha: 有您这句话我就放心了
Tasha: With that, I'm reassured.
Alice:不知道能给它弄着不
Alice: Not sure if we can light it up.
Shure: 咱保底不是还有外卖吗
Shure: We can always order takeout as a backup.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 不行这些就拿
Shure: If it doesn't work, just take these.
Shure: 锅一炒
Shure: And stir-fry them.
Tasha: 我已经做了第二种甜品了
Tasha: I've already made the second dessert.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 剩下这些不行
Shure: The rest won't work.
Lucia: backup plan
Lucia: Backup plan.
Katrina: 我要吃一块披萨
Katrina: I want a piece of pizza.
Shure: 还可以炒
Shure: We can still stir-fry.
Alice:没有明火是不行的
Alice: It won't work without an open flame.
Tasha: 您OK了吧
Tasha: Are you okay now?
Tasha: OK了OK了
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Jake:还不行
Jake: Still not okay.
Tasha: 啊嗯
Tasha: Ah, hmm.
Lucia: 好了好了好了
Lucia: Alright, alright, alright.
Shure: 我们可以这样
Shure: We can do it this way.
Tasha: 来吧放在这里这里
Tasha: Come on, put it here, here.
Alice:会有点危险
Alice: It might be a bit dangerous.
Lucia: 放在哪里
Lucia: Put it where?
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Tasha: 然后继续搅
Tasha: And then keep stirring.
Tasha: 对对不我说等会继续搅
Tasha: Yes, yes, no I mean keep stirring later.
Tasha: 是不是应该换个大点
Tasha: Should we use a bigger one?
Jake:这个是要做什么
Jake: What's this for?
Tasha: 这个这个就做第2种甜品
Tasha: This, this is for the second dessert.
Alice:这上面我有一点点纠结
Alice: I'm a bit confused about this part.
Tasha: 就纸杯蛋糕呀
Tasha: It's just cupcakes.
Tasha: 可以爆浆
Tasha: They can be molten.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:笑死
Alice: LOL
Lucia: 听起来就好好吃哦
Lucia: It sounds so delicious.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:就这个纸杯吗
Jake: Is it just this paper cup?
Alice:送入烤箱
Alice: Put it in the oven.
Lucia: 对就咱们那天做的那种
Lucia: Yeah, just like the ones we made the other day.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Tasha: 但是再升升升升级也可以
Tasha: But we can keep upgrading it.
Shure: 不行我就把这个轱辘一直放在地下烧
Shure: If not, I'll keep burning this wheel on the ground.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:给他弄灭了吧
Alice: Put it out for him.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 开始搅拌
Lucia: Start stirring.
Tasha: 搅拌到看不到面粉就行
Tasha: Stir until you can't see the flour anymore.
Tasha: 甜点大师诞生了
Tasha: A dessert master is born.
Shure: 然后再浇点酒精上面
Shure: Then pour some alcohol on top.
Shure: 奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Tasha: 两位两位后厨人员配一位大师
Tasha: Two kitchen staff for each master.
Shure: 我真不信
Shure: I really don't believe it.
Lucia: 哈哈大师
Lucia: Hahaha master
Shure: 原来也没这么难着这些东西
Lucia: 等一下啊好吧
Lucia: Wait a minute, okay.
Lucia: 我怎么给他擦的和成面了都哈哈哈
Lucia: How did I wipe it and it turned into dough, hahaha.
Shure: 不行我们考9,100
Shure: No way, we need a score of 9,100.
Shure: 哈哈考他
Shure: Hahaha test him.
Alice:这得多少酒精烧啊
Alice: How much alcohol does this need to burn?
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Tasha: OK我们可以把蛋清那个啊
Tasha: OK, we can add the egg whites now.
Tasha: 对对可以下一步
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, we can move to the next step.
Shure: 帅不帅哈哈哈哈
Shure: Isn't it cool? Hahahaha
Katrina: 帅
Katrina: Cool.
Katrina: 像魔术师一样
Katrina: Like a magician.
Tasha: 哇哇有种大厨的感觉
Tasha: Wow, it feels like a master chef.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 好搞笑啊
Katrina: So funny.
Katrina: 特别是他在那打仗
Katrina: Especially him fighting there.
Alice:等一下你到最后一点
Alice: Wait, at the very end...
Alice:给你照个相
Alice: I'll take a picture of you.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Alice:等等等稍等一下
Alice: Wait, wait, wait, hold on.
Katrina: 特别像在表演魔术
Katrina: It's like you're performing magic.
Shure: 你一定要刷的帅一下
Shure: You gotta do it with style.
Tasha: 糖35克
Tasha: 35 grams of sugar.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 糖35克玉米淀粉10克
Tasha: 35 grams of sugar and 10 grams of corn starch.
Shure: 很帅起来
Shure: Looking good.
Tasha: 你要来打发
Tasha: Do you want to whip it?
Tasha: 打发吗
Tasha: Whip it?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure.
Tasha: 可以哎把那个头拿来就行对
Tasha: Yeah, just bring that head over, right.
Lucia: 呃安上是吧好嘞
Lucia: Uh, just attach it, right, okay.
Tasha: 安上之后先挤点柠檬汁进去
Tasha: After attaching it, squeeze some lemon juice in.
Tasha: 然后再开始打
Tasha: Then start whipping.
Alice:烧点硬盘
Alice: Burn some hard drive.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Alice:他们都不是
Alice: They're not...
Shure: 他们都只红了一点点
Shure: They just got a little bit red.
Alice:有个小夹呢
Alice: Where's the small clip?
Shure: 这不行这不行
Shure: This isn't working.
Shure: 不能这么少
Shure: Can't be this little.
Tasha: 啊哦
Tasha: Ah, oh.
Lucia: 哦我来帮你挤我来帮你挤
Lucia: Oh, let me help you squeeze it.
Shure: 这么烧肯他妈的要出事
Shure: Burning it like this is gonna cause trouble, damn it.
Tasha: 哦你们在这
Tasha: Oh, you guys are here.
Tasha: 我刚没有看到
Tasha: I didn't see you just now.
Alice:聊胜于无吧
Alice: Better than nothing, I guess.
Tasha: 怎么办挤了一颗种子进去
Tasha: What to do, a seed got in.
Shure: 卧槽这烧的快啊
Shure: Damn, it's burning fast.
Tasha: 我直接用手拿他
Tasha: I'll just grab it by hand.
Shure: 这呼一下就烧起来了
Shure: It flared up just like that.
Tasha: 他怎么这么不听话
Tasha: Why is it being so disobedient?
Tasha: 我靠哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh man, haha.
Shure: 嗯这烧透了
Shure: Yep, it burned through.
Shure: 还是这书就是刚才
Shure: Or maybe it was just...
Tasha: 怎么个角度法呢
Tasha: Which angle should it be?
Shure: 原来那本来就烧起来的
Shure: It was already burning before.
Lucia: 然后把它调到
Lucia: Then adjust it to...
Tasha: 对对对对对对对对对对
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:看今天是8,000美金
Alice: Look, today is $8,000.
Lucia: 直接调到五
Lucia: Just set it to five.
Shure: 看今天是8,000美金先报
Shure: Look, today is $8,000. Report it first.
Katrina: 今天是发现内空线爆
Katrina: Today we found the inner line explosion.
Alice:线爆还是我们前十啊
Alice: The line explosion, are we still in the top ten?
Shure: 还是我们先吃上饭好吧
Shure: Shouldn't we eat first?
Katrina: 还是我们现实的版爆
Katrina: Or is it our realistic version explosion?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:不在那边一会那个火星泼你身上
Alice: Don't stay there, or the sparks will splash on you in a bit.
Katrina: 这么难这么难
Katrina: So hard, so hard.
Tasha: 来吧继续抽
Tasha: Come on, keep drawing.
Shure: 人生没有容易2字懂了吗
Shure: Life is never easy, got it?
Tasha: 哎用这个抽就可以了啊
Tasha: Hey, just use this to draw, okay?
Tasha: 好吧你用这个抽也可以
Tasha: Okay, you can use this to draw too.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 呃可以
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Shure: 这时候现在知道谁知盘中餐
Shure: Now you know how hard it is to get a meal.
Shure: 粒粒皆辛苦了吧
Shure: Every grain is hard work, right?
Tasha: 好对
Tasha: Yes, exactly.
Lucia: 可以了
Lucia: It's good now.
Tasha: 可以了然后然后加糖
Tasha: It's good now, then add sugar.
Katrina: 此时拍有温度
Katrina: It's warm now.
Shure: 其实它有温度了
Shure: Actually, it is warm now.
Tasha: 就是糖分三次加
Tasha: Just add the sugar in three batches.
Tasha: 你看第一次就这种
Tasha: Look, the first time, it's like this.
Lucia: 你看
Lucia: Look.
Tasha: 有这种粗粗的气孔的时候加
Tasha: When there are coarse bubbles, add it.
Tasha: 然后呢打到那种没有粗粗的气孔
Tasha: Then, beat it until there are no coarse bubbles.
Tasha: 打到绵密的气孔的时候加第二次
Tasha: When the bubbles are fine, add the second batch.
Lucia: 绵密的气孔
Lucia: Fine bubbles.
Shure: 妈妈说你快远离这个是非之地
Shure: Mom said you should stay away from trouble.
Alice:看就差不多了
Alice: Look, it's almost done.
Shure: 对其实差不多了
Shure: Yes, it's almost done.
Alice:你就搁那别动就行
Alice: Just leave it there, don't move it.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Lucia: 这样看起来还可以
Lucia: It looks pretty good like this.
Tasha: 这就是绵密气孔
Tasha: These are the fine bubbles.
Shure: sorry吧你
Shure: Sorry, you.
Tasha: 然后再加第二
Tasha: Then add the second.
Tasha: 第二次烫可以多加一点
Tasha: For the second heating, you can add a bit more.
Tasha: 让他帮助他定型
Tasha: It helps set the shape.
Tasha: 然后还剩一点点就是最后成型
Tasha: And then just a little more for the final shaping.
Shure: 这个丁烷还是丙烷
Shure: Is this butane or propane?
Lucia: 这个这次要打到大概什么样呃打到
Lucia: How much do we need to heat this...?
Shure: 他这个燃烧温度比
Shure: The burning temperature is...
Tasha: 呃打到
Tasha: Um, heat it until...
Tasha: 你看着打吧
Tasha: Just heat it until you feel it’s right.
Lucia: 啊哈哈就是
Lucia: Ahahaha, I see.
Shure: 天然气好像会高一点
Shure: Natural gas seems to be a bit higher.
Alice:我觉得可以上烤盘了
Alice: I think it’s ready to go on the grill.
Lucia: 眼线好像还有一点
Lucia: It looks like there’s still some eyeliner.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Alice:嗯还挺烧的
Alice: Yeah, it’s still pretty hot.
Lucia: 那个啥我眼镜往下滑了
Lucia: My glasses keep slipping down.
Katrina: 特别可怜
Katrina: That’s so pitiful.
Alice:还挺热的了
Alice: It’s still quite hot.
Alice:好就这样吧
Alice: Alright, let’s leave it at that.
Katrina: 这是我们的房间
Katrina: This is our room.
Katrina: 他们在这吃
Katrina: They’re eating here.
Tasha: 稳定了吗
Tasha: Is it stable now?
Katrina: 他们在做甜品
Katrina: They’re making desserts.
Lucia: 刚才好像还不太行
Lucia: It didn’t seem quite right earlier.
Lucia: 稍等现在再试一下
Lucia: Hold on, let’s try it again now.
Shure: 这也着了
Shure: This is also burning.
Alice:你试试这个温度上
Alice: Try this temperature.
Tasha: 差不多差不多嘛
Tasha: Almost there, almost.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Lucia: 还是这样搅
Lucia: Still stir it like this.
Tasha: 嗯你加5克玉米淀粉进去
Tasha: Yeah, add 5 grams of cornstarch.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Go ahead, go ahead.
Alice:哎呀我来
Alice: Oh, let me do it.
Tasha: 他就会成定的更快一点
Tasha: It’ll set faster this way.
Shure: 不行就多烤会呗
Shure: If it’s not enough, bake it longer.
Shure: 咱慢慢熏
Shure: We’ll smoke it slowly.
Alice:小火慢煨
Alice: Simmer it on low heat.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 我终于知道
Shure: I finally understand.
Shure: 我爸为什么每次都不买这种长条
Shure: Why my dad never buys this long strip.
Shure: 他说易燃
Shure: He said it’s flammable.
Shure: 但是根本就一点都不易燃
Shure: But it's not flammable at all.
Katrina: 这是做的蛋糕
Katrina: This is a cake we made.
Shure: 都是假的
Shure: It's all fake.
Tasha: 嗯可以
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Katrina: 我们今天又去
Katrina: Today we went to
Katrina: 超市了
Katrina: the supermarket again.
Tasha: 你你你这样子
Tasha: You, you, you, like this.
Katrina: 这我们买的东西
Katrina: These are the things we bought.
Tasha: 你其实这样子
Tasha: You actually, like this.
Tasha: 就是空白的地方
Tasha: It's just an empty space.
Shure: 这一点没着的
Shure: This part isn't lit.
Tasha: 他就转出来了
Tasha: It just turned out.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 哦哈哈
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Alice:其实我觉得可以放上去
Alice: Actually, I think we can put it on.
Katrina: 我们不用干活
Katrina: We don't need to work.
Alice:你试一下这个温度
Alice: Try this temperature.
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see.
Katrina: 我们戴眼镜就算干活了呀
Katrina: Wearing glasses counts as working, right?
Shure: 来吧先咱们小范围烤着
Shure: Come on, let's bake a small batch first.
Shure: 烤着一点吃
Shure: Bake a bit and eat.
Lucia: 取下来
Lucia: Take it off.
Shure: 好吧不然话真快饿死了大家
Shure: Okay, otherwise everyone will be really hungry.
Katrina: 是我们每天的
Katrina: That's our daily routine.
Lucia: 然后这个就可以洗掉了是吧
Lucia: Then this can be washed off, right?
Katrina: 天午饭
Katrina: Lunch.
Tasha: 对洗掉
Tasha: Yes, wash it off.
Shure: 是的是的肯定有用
Shure: Yes, yes, it will definitely work.
Katrina: 去公园去买烤肉
Katrina: Go to the park to buy barbecue.
Tasha: 对他洗掉之后还有用
Tasha: Yes, it still works after washing.
Katrina: 排骨没了
Katrina: The ribs are gone.
Lucia: 就是打发奶油要用
Lucia: It's for whipping cream.
Tasha: 就是打发奶油要用
Tasha: It's for whipping cream.
Shure: 只要鼓鼓手的手速
Shure: Just need the drummer's hand speed.
Lucia: 哦好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Shure: 这时候就能用上了
Shure: You can use it now.
Lucia: 所以橄榄油应该是一会才用吧
Lucia: So the olive oil should be used later, right?
Tasha: 嗯等蛋糕胚烤好再打
Tasha: Hmm, after the cake base is baked.
Shure: 咱不有吹风机吗
Shure: Don't we have a hairdryer?
Katrina: 这是做纸杯蛋糕吗
Katrina: Is this for making cupcakes?
Lucia: OK
Tasha: 嗯做两种蛋糕
Tasha: Yeah, let's make two kinds of cakes.
Shure: 啊也是
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure: 从从那个屋顺出一个插排
Shure: Let's run an extension cord from that room.
Tasha: 因为感嗯太咸了
Tasha: Because, um, it's too salty.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Tasha: 感觉外面
Tasha: Feels like outside.
Alice:你去准备那啥吧我扇会
Alice: You go and prepare that, I'll fan for a bit.
Katrina: 外面的火还没起来呢
Katrina: The fire outside hasn't started yet.
Tasha: 还没起来
Tasha: Hasn't started yet.
Alice:哎是不是这个就可以用了
Alice: Hey, can we use this?
Katrina: 他那个炭烧不着
Katrina: The charcoal isn't burning.
Katrina: 学了呀我今天还学了
Katrina: I learned it, yeah, I learned it today.